website at help.senate.gov
and if you are in need of accommodations
included closed captioning you can reach
out to the committee or to the office of
congressional accessibility services
a few months ago president biden
announced his plan to respond to the
delta variant which was surging and
jeopardizing our hard-won progress
against coven 19.
and while our work continues the
president's decisive action and the hard
work of experts and public health
officials across the country
have put us in a stronger position to
end this pandemic
right now cases hospitalizations and
deaths are once again trending down and
the vaccination rate is continuing to go
up
nearly 80 percent of people age 12 and
older have gotten their first dose of
cobin 19 vaccine nearly 70 percent have
been fully vaccinated and inequities and
vaccination numbers have been narrowing
we are also also already seeing how
requirements for vaccines are testing
like president biden has called for and
which a clear majority of americans
support can bring vaccination rates even
higher as of last month vaccine
requirements had increased vaccination
rates by over 20 percent
united airlines has seen their
vaccination rate for employees go from
57 to 99
since they announced their vaccine
requirement
tyson foods went from less than half of
its workers vaccinated to over 96
percent
in my home state of washington 15 and 16
of our state's workers have already
complied with the gov governor inslee's
vaccine requirement and across the
country health care facilities
universities and other employers are
seeing similar research results
and i expect that progress to continue
now that the department of labor has put
forward an emergency temporary standard
on this issue we're also seeing progress
on booster shots with three different
booster shots authorized and over 13
million already administered and on
shots for children younger than 12 with
the fda authorizing vaccines for
children ages 5 to 11 last week and the
cdc issuing its decision on this
recently
but even with all the progress we've
made so far we must not take our foot
off the gas last winter we saw this
virus push our hospitals to the brink we
saw it infect and kill hundreds of
thousands of people including essential
workers and health care workers and we
know it led to burnout among so many
more
vaccines are one of our best tools for
making sure that does not happen again
and making sure we can build back from
this pandemic stronger and fairer
in fact as the white house noted in its
report on vaccination requirements an
outside economic analysis found that
increasing vaccination and reaching near
full vaccination in workplaces could
encourage millions of people
to return to the workforce
tests also continue to serve a critical
role in stopping the spread by informing
our ongoing response which is why we
need to plan to scale up testing even
more
and in a larger sense we must learn the
lessons of this pandemic not only so we
can prepare for the winter ahead but so
we can finally bring an end to this
pandemic and be better prepared for the
next public health crisis whatever it
may be
i've been pressing to get that done at
every possible opportunity and it's why
senator burr and i continue to work on
bipartisan public health and
preparedness legislation
and it's also why i'm pushing for
critical steps and build back better to
strengthen our public health
infrastructure among other things build
back better will help public health
departments across the country increase
their testing and tracing capacity
train and retain public health workers
upgrade to more modern inclusive and
interoperable data systems communicate
with the public and address
misinformation about issues like
vaccines and address health inequities
and build partnerships in hard to reach
communities
it would also help our federal federal
public health agencies like the fda cdc
and the assistant secretary for
preparedness and response take action to
increase lab capacity so we can sequence
viruses and identify variants quickly
facilitate the development of new
treatments and tests and vaccines and
improve the supply chain of medical
supplies like syringes ventilators and
personal protective equipment
this pandemic has been long
and it has been deadly it has hurt our
economy our communities and our families
beyond measure but if we continue to
take bold action if we continue to
follow the science and experts if we
continue to get people vaccinated and
take steps to keep ourselves and those
around us safe we will get through this
and if we learn from this pandemic if we
finally end the
cycle of crisis and complacency for
public health funding and ensure we have
an economy that works for everyone not
just those at the top we can rebuild our
country stronger and fairer and we can
make sure we are never in a situation
like this again with that i will turn it
over to ranking member for his opening
statement
thank you madam chairman to our
witnesses uh welcome back to the help
committee
i get the
feeling that we may need to send smoke
signals to you um i'm not sure we could
have gotten you further away from us and
everybody but we're grateful to you and
we thank you for your service to the
american people
each time you've all come before the
committee i charged you to look ahead
the next 30 60 and 90 days and figure
out where we needed to be and what we
needed to do to keep up with this virus
i'll say it again
you are the adults in the room
and you need to look for a look around
the corner to anticipate what we will
need
more than 90 days from our last hearing
and we still have much to do to ensure
that we're better prepared and better at
responding than we've been in previous
weeks and months
as we get closer to the two-year mark of
living with covet 19
we need to take stock of the current
state of our response
and
identify the next critical steps that
will lead us out senator murray and i
have been working closely together to
develop a pandemic bill and at some
point in the near future senator murray
and i will release a discussion draft of
the reform and we believe
[Music]
this is needed for our country's future
response
i very much appreciate the ability to
work together on an issue so important
to our national security
we've obviously delayed from our
previous uh schedule
but given the intent to appear on other
big legislation it is impossible for us
to get that draft out until that's
concluded
we need to use all the tools at our
disposal to keep pace with the virus
which continues to evolve
recent reports have surfaced of a new
sub-variant that some are calling delta
plus
which is which has accounted for an
increasing proportion of cases in the uk
in the past month
i hope to discuss that in person when i
leave
sunday for the uk
and
[Music]
spend some time in london next week
to look at in fact what delta plus has
done there
that mistake cases and hospitalizations
are down in the united states
but the administration cannot declare
premature victory
like we did in the summer
the mistake only brought us to a place
we are today with shortages of tests
therapeutics and continued lag in
extremely important data about the
disease
in september even cdc warned of
shortages in point of care and
over-the-counter tests and to expect
increased demand for lab-based testing
to state the obvious we need more rapid
tests that are available and in stock
north carolinians are calling my office
desperate for help in accessing
therapeutics and even with new
announcements on oral therapeutics
americans are waiting for these drugs
this administration bears 100 of the
responsibility for the lack of testing
and the lack of therapies
you got complacent
you let your foot off the gas you didn't
order enough tests you didn't purchase
enough therapeutics and now we're
rationing
the private sector will respond to
purchasing agreements in the contracts
they cannot and will not produce things
that customers are not ordering
congress has given billions of dollars
and billions more of dollars we've
demonstrated bipartisan commitment to
giving you the cover to purchase
vaccines test therapeutics even if we
don't use them
the administration squandered time and
resources you've already had available
to you and the american people are
suffering as a result
as we look ahead
we need plans in place to handle covet
as an endemic
disease
that will be part of our lives for the
foreseeable future
so my question in the headline for this
hearing is simple
what's the plan
we need to take stock of lessons learned
to strengthen our ability to be ready
for the next threat that we may face
but also learn from successful
approaches and put those into everyday
practice
we need to identify information gaps and
map out how we're going to address
them so that we can make the best
decisions based on sound sites and sound
data
most importantly we need strong
leadership
we need a nominee for the fda
commissioner and this administration
cannot drag its feet on a new leader at
the nih
both nominees will have challenging
missions to complete
under difficult circumstances and nearly
impossible shoes to fill
qualified non-partisan leadership at
these agencies is paramount dr woodcock
i'm still rooting for you
we must leverage the laboratory
community and test developers to bring
more innovative rapid at home and point
of care test to market
we need not let our guard down as we did
this summer
we're reaching the time of the year
where we're all looking forward to
spending time with loved ones and access
to testing
will help this happen safely
but we're still behind these tests which
we need to keep our businesses and
schools open and families safe are still
far too difficult to find for most
americans
testing shortages and delayed tests
results are keeping children out of
school parents away from the office and
limiting our understanding of where
virus is circulating in our communities
the administration had to scramble to
order 200 million
at-home tests per month
many of which won't even be ready until
december
and that's not enough
in early october fda announced that it
authorized new tests to expand access to
reliable at-home testing
europe's been using these same tests for
seven months
just this past weekend
my two-year-old grandson was notified on
friday that his teacher tested positive
teacher of a
preschool
class
mask 100 of the time that they were
there
they did the appropriate thing they shut
the class down for a week
the problem was that his siblings
could no longer go to school
school not only required him to be
tested
before
his sister could return to school
but didn't accept an at-home test
for a negative test for the two-year-old
they required a pcr test
it's confusing
america does not understand the
standards that we've set and in that
case
she lost three days of school
even though
they could afford the pcr test how many
families can't
the american people are tired of
accepting better late than never from
our public health agencies and the
testing shortage will only get more
pronounced if the department of labor
issues its threatening temporary
standard which it did right before
we came in which will create an even
larger demand for tests for those who
don't choose to get vaccinated
one recent survey found that 59 of
unvaccinated workers are still
not likely to get vaccinated
despite the mandates from this
administration
with a heavy-handed vaccine federal
mandates on employers this
administration completely disregards the
legitimate question raised by many
americans and specifically dr paul and
marshall
what role does natural immunity play in
protecting against this virus
i've said before that i did not believe
that the federal government mandates
will solve our problem
we're seeing cops and firefighters quit
and pilots engage in sick outs the
nation's military and contractors worry
about our preparedness if personnel are
fired over these mandates and just this
morning
a mandate from cms to all health care
providers that accept medicare and
medicaid that if they don't mandate to
their workforce they're no longer
participants in medicare or medicaid
will only suggest to doctors not to
accept medicare or medicaid patients
if in fact they choose as a medical
professional
not to be vaccinated
so
there likely will be controversies over
whether to require the vaccine for
children
when even your own experts raise great
concerns about mandating children get
vaccines
i urge
all of you
back away from mandates
and instead use your platforms to
educate encourage inform
don't be divisive
while more therapeutics and more tests
are the tools that we need to manage the
constant demands of the virus we also
need better information to make the best
decisions
we need real-time data to understand and
get ahead of covit today
and to detect the next emerging
infectious disease or public health
threat in the future
so far congress has dedicated 1.1
billion dollars to improve our public
health data sharing
and turn it into an actionable
information through our surveillance
system
but we still do not have the up-to-date
and actionable data we need to answer
some of the most common questions from
the american people
effective communication of information
and data is the best way for the public
health officials to win back the trust
of the american people
and it's clear to me that the cdc has
lost the trust of the american people
show americans the evidence
for why the tough choices are the right
ones
and don't just expect the compliance get
you there
use the best information available at
the time even if it isn't perfect
and update action as the information
evolves
this is a particular challenge for what
is supposed to be our leading public
health agency the cdc
an agency that i have watched agonize
over
having perfect clean data to make
decisions for americans
by the time we get their data
it's too late
we still don't have the answers to basic
questions
we need real usable information about
masks
how well do different types of mass work
when should we use them the cdc
continues to change its posture on the
collection of information on
breakthrough cases
how many breakthrough cases result in
hospitalization
how many do not
cdc is not in a place where the nation
looks
for real-time data and we need to change
that
the cdc is too focused on writing
academic papers about something that
happened weeks or months ago
when americans want real data they're
forced to look elsewhere like john
hopkins university or hhs hhs
protect
i worry the new approach to hhs protect
will not be able to overcome the
complacent academic culture of cdc
without serious reforms so i'll be
watching very carefully
we must all come to terms with the
reality the virus
is here to stay
it's vital that the four of you sitting
here today take the initiative to lead
empower americans with data tools and
clear and actionable guidance needed to
get back to normal
the more people that get vaccinated to
protect against covet the better the
more tests available to americans to
detect and diagnose covet the better
the more therapeutics we have to rapidly
treat covet the better
the more we can continue to learn from
this experience the better prepared we
will be
i thank the chair
thank you senator burr i will now
introduce today's witnesses again thank
you for joining us today um dr rachelle
wolinski is the director of the centers
for disease control and prevention and
the administrator of the agency for
toxic substances and disease registry dr
anthony fauci is the director of the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases and the chief
medical advisor on pre president biden's
coven 19 response team
dr janet woodcock is the acting
commissioner of the food and drug
administration and donald connell is the
assistant secretary for preparedness and
response
dr wolenski director fauci acting
commissioner woodcock and assistant
secretary o'connell thank you all for
joining us once again we look forward to
your testimony and dr wolenski we will
begin with you
good morning chair murray ranking member
burr members of the senate health
committee i'm honored to join you today
to provide an update on the covet 19
pandemic
since i last testified before this
committee on july 20th we have witnessed
a steep increase in kova 19 cases
hospitalizations and deaths around the
nation largely fueled by the delta
variant
the delta variant reminded us we need to
be humble in our response to this virus
and to follow the science as we modify
guidance and address the pandemic
here are a few things we've learned over
the last four months
first the delta variant is notably more
contagious and spreads faster than
previous variants second though
breakthrough infections are infrequent
vaccinated individuals who are infected
with delta are able to transmit the
virus
and third while we have seen waning
vaccine-induced immunity in certain
populations leading us to recommend the
roll out of booster shots covet 19
vaccines are still highly effective and
provide strong protection particularly
against severe disease hospitalization
and death
while we are once again pleased to see
downward trends in cases this decline
seems to be slowing and deaths are not
falling nearly as fast as we would like
on average we still see over a thousand
deaths every day
and tragically there have been more than
138 000 deaths since i last spoke here
as we look towards the coming weeks and
months with some optimism we must
remember what the delta variant did to
this country erasing weeks of prior
progress and long downward trends and
reminding us that this novel coronavirus
is unpredictable
in addition we're entering the winter
season where we are predicting an
increase in influenza and other
respiratory viruses we are concerned
about this year's flu season has the
potential to be severe
it's just as important as ever to get
vaccinated for covid and for influenza
we've made incredible strides in
vaccinating the us population against
covet 19.
as of november 3rd we have vaccinated
about 85 percent of the united states
population 65 years and older 70 of
those 18 years and older 68 of those 12
years and older and nearly 58 percent of
the entire united states population
some of our latest data only reinforce
why vaccination is so very important
showing that unvaccinated people have
six times greater risk of testing
positive for cova 19 and 11 times
greater risk of dying from coven 19 than
people who are fully vaccinated
importantly we now have data showing
that the pfizer vaccine is nearly 91
percent effective in preventing cova-19
infection in children ages 5-11 who did
not have coven-19 infection previously
why is this such important news
case surveillance data indicate that
there have been 9 000 hospitalizations
among children ages 5 to 11 since the
beginning of the pandemic
mortality data have recorded more than
97 deaths in this age group
there are now well over 5 000 children
diagnosed with misc and living with
complications of this disease
as a mother i know that no parent should
have to see their child face long-term
complications or of an infection or be
hospitalized and we now have a highly
effective tool to prevent this disease
in our children
following fda's authorization i endorsed
cdc's advisory committee on immunization
practices recommendation that children
ages 5 and up should receive a covet 19
vaccine
i strongly encourage parents and their
children to get vaccinated and if you
have any questions about the vaccine
please talk to your child's pediatrician
a school nurse your local pharmacist or
a trusted medical professional
in addition to the critical work to get
out of this pandemic through vaccination
and other prevention strategies we need
to better prepare for future outbreaks
and pandemics
one of the most important steps we can
take to support these efforts is to
support sustained disease agnostic
funding for public health
this is how we will accomplish our goals
to rebuild our public health workforce
invest in our public health laboratory
infrastructure ensure rapid response
readiness and improve our ability to
collect and use data
i hope these bipartisan goals for
members of this committee and i look
forward to continuing to work with you
to achieve these investments
before i close i want to emphasize that
the work we've done collectively to
invest in and distribute vaccines has
given us our most powerful tool to get
out of this pandemic
data show again and again that vaccines
work they are safe and they can save
your life
thank you i look forward to your
questions thank you dr fauci
this doesn't seem to work it works we
can hear you
madam chair ranking member burr
members of the committee
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to discuss with you
the role of the national institute of
allergy and infectious diseases
in the conduct and support of research
addressing our nation's response to
covet 19.
in previous hearings before this
committee
i've discussed the critical role of niad
in the development of covert 19 vaccines
their testing and clinical trials
as well as the proof of their real world
effectiveness
today i would like to focus my remarks
on studies aimed at optimizing the
degree and durability of protection
offered by these vaccines in addition
i will mention our recent work in the
development of effective therapies to
prevent the progression of covert 19
disease
and i'll close by briefly mentioning our
involvement in preparedness for future
pandemic threats
it has become apparent as we follow
cohorts of vaccinated individuals over
time
that the durability of protection
afforded by the vaccines both against
infection and the development of severe
disease
gradually wanes over time
this has led to a considerable amount of
activity
aimed at optimizing protection
by boosting with an additional dose of
vaccine
several months after the primary regimen
one can gauge the effect of these
booster shots
by measuring the induction of high
levels of neutralizing antibody
as well as the clinical effect of
enhanced protection
and in this regard it has become clear
that giving a third boost of an mrna
vaccine approximately six months or more
following the original primary regimen
provides a dramatic enhancement of
protection
against infection as well as severe
disease and in the studies from israel
this is beginning to be seen across all
age groups
in this regard
certain subsets of individuals who have
received any of the three vaccines
available in this country
are now eligible for booster shots
importantly
to increase the flexibility of the
administration of boosters
niaid has conducted a critical study
which is called mix and match
in which individuals are divided into
three groups representing each of the
three available products
these individuals were then boosted
with a product other than the original
one with which they were vaccinated
data clearly indicated
that boosting with a different product
in the original
was both safe
and indeed induced
a robust immune response
thus
although we recommend that people boost
with the original product of their
vaccination
this study adds a degree of flexibility
by allowing a choice of booster shots
if it is difficult for one reason or
another to receive the original product
let me now move on to a brief discussion
of the niid research approach to
therapeutics
particularly in the context
of treating an individual early in the
course of infection
to prevent progression to severe disease
the niaid has initiated a program called
the antiviral program for pandemics
which is aimed at catalyzing the
development of new medications to combat
covert 19 as well as to prepare
for future pandemic threats
the program has two pillars
one takes existing drugs and accelerates
their clinical testing and advanced
development
and the other pursues the discovery of
new molecules
aimed at various vulnerable components
of the sauce kobe 2 replication cycle
one compound in particular
malnu pirovir
developed by merck and ridgeback
companies has shown considerable promise
in a recently conducted clinical trial
in which the drug was administered early
in the course of infection
and it decreased hospitalization and
death
by 50
in the treated individuals
compared to the placebo group
i bring this to your attention
because the very early work on this
molecule
was the result of nih grant support to
academic institutions
for the fundamental basic research which
led to the discovery and the development
of this molecule
finally
i would like to close by looking forward
to how we might best enhance our
preparedness for what will be the
inevitable future pandemics
in this regard
the nih has already initiated its plans
for the rapid development and
implementation of successful
countermeasures against several
prototype pathogen families of viruses
that threaten the health and safety not
only of our nation
but of the entire world
i look forward to describing these plans
to you in more detail
thank you for your attention and i would
be happy to answer your questions
following the presentation
thank you dr woodcock
having the same there we go great
good morning chair murray ranking member
burr and members of the committee thanks
for the opportunity to testify here
today and
and for the continued bipartisan efforts
of your committee to address the coveted
19 pandemic
fda appreciates the productive
discussions and we look forward to
continuing our partnership on these
legislative efforts
fda has achieved some of the most
impressive scientific based regulatory
advances i've seen during my higher
entire career at the agency during this
pandemic driven by our mission to
protect public health
i know the american public has been
eager to hear about getting their
children vaccinated what they can do if
they get sick with covid19 and how they
can further protect themselves and their
loved ones against the virus
let me provide a brief update on the
actions the agency has taken to protect
public health in three key areas since i
last testified before this committee
first regarding vaccines
fda has authorized three covid19
vaccines and approved one vaccine
these have met fda's expectations for
safety and effectiveness appropriate
either for authorization or approval in
preventing covet 19.
in the last few weeks the agencies made
additional critical decisions about the
use of these vaccines
fda authorized booster doses for use in
certain populations for all three
authorized vaccines as you've just heard
from our other witnesses
as more data became available the data
suggested the effectiveness of the
initial doses had started to wane
meaning that use of a booster dose would
be important in bolstering protection
for these populations
and the agency also authorized the use
of mix-and-match booster doses for
covid19 using data from niad as was just
mentioned
this means eligible individuals can get
any of the three authorized vaccines as
their booster dose and
really simplifies
availability for the public
also fda authorized the pfizer vaccine
for use in children ages 5 through 11.
i know because i've
had many messages on this many parents
have been waiting impatiently for months
for this authorization
and i'm happy to say as we speak here
today young children across the country
are starting to get vaccinated against
covet
and to be clear fda is confident in the
safety and effectiveness data behind
these decisions
the american public can and should feel
confident in receiving any of these
vaccines they will help bring this
pandemic to an end and i strongly
encourage all eligible americans to get
vaccinated and get their children
vaccinated we all have an important role
to play here
second diagnostic tests are a key line
of defense in the pandemic and will
become increasingly important i think
increasing access to accurate rapid
at-home tests is a priority for fda
we prioritizes
the review of at home rapid antigen test
and we're actively engaging with test
developers to increase their
availability
last month the agency authorized
additional over-the-counter at-home
tests which we expect to significantly
increase the availability of rapid tests
to the public
these authorizations add to a growing
list of tests that can be used at home
without a prescription in the us
additionally last week fba provided
recommendations for labeling updates to
facilitate better over-the-counter
single-use testing for symptomatic
people
in tests currently they're only
authorized for serial testing this
change allows tests to be sold as single
tests meaning greater availability of
more individual tests
fda remains focused on speeding the
process to get appropriately accurate
and reliable tests in the hands of all
americans who need one
third there's a need for medical
products to treat and prevent covid19
especially for those unable to get
vaccinated or who don't develop an
immune response we continue to carefully
evaluate the data on any promising
therapeutics and our priority is to have
fast discussions between fda and drug
sponsors
we are hoping that we will see more
therapeutics authorized soon to treat
covet 19 in the future as another weapon
in our arsenal
and finally i want to stress that all of
fda's work and effort is toward the goal
of protecting the public it's a
responsibility we take seriously and we
rely on science this is what allows us
to expedite development and availability
of medical products to address covet 19.
thank you and i look forward to your
questions
thank you assistant secretary o'connell
chair murray ranking member burr and
distinguished members of the committee
it is an honor to testify before you
today
i am pleased to have this opportunity to
provide a few key updates that have
occurred in asper since i last testified
before you in july
ensuring the nation has the necessary
vaccines therapeutics and diagnostics to
respond to covid19 remains a primary
focus of asper's response to date barda
has supported 77 medical countermeasure
projects this includes 15 therapeutics
55 diagnostics and seven vaccine
candidates
notably as part of the countermeasures
acceleration group effort with dod
barda has placed 1.5 billion doses of
vaccine under contract distributed over
4.88 million doses of monoclonal
antibodies and shipped more than
144 million diagnostic kits
accelerating the supply of available
rapid point-of-care and over-the-counter
tests has been another important focus
of asperger's work
while there is currently enough testing
capacity across all types of tests we
have seen a growing preference for rapid
tests
especially those that can be used at
home
over the last few months asper has
invested over 3 billion dollars to bring
additional rapid point of care and
at-home tests to market with one billion
dollars of that going specifically to
at-home tests
as production has ramped up since
september
these investments put us on pace to
quadruple by december the number of
at-home tests available each month to
nearly 200 million
supporting hospitals and healthcare
systems that are overwhelmed by covid19
patients is another important focus of
asper's response
since july 27 national disaster medical
system teams nearly 600 team members
have deployed to support sites in 12
separate states
we currently have teams in wisconsin new
mexico and montana for these deployments
ndms personnel support a range of
functions
including hospital augmentation and
decompression setting up medical
overflow centers for patients and
offering mortuary support
ensuring our health care providers and
first responders have the necessary
medical supplies they need remains a
focus of asper's efforts
as of october 1st the strategic national
stockpile or s s
shipped more than 250 million items to
aid the national response over the
course of the pandemic including
deploying more than 3 000 ventilators to
seventeen jurisdictions since i last
testified
and we continue our work to replenish
the s s to levels at or above
pre-coveted 19 amounts
thanks in large part to the supplemental
funding congress has provided the s s
has spent approximately 11.9 billion
dollars to replenish the inventory
including purchasing from domestic
manufacturers whenever possible
while replenishing the s s is essential
we continue to address the root cause of
why public health supply chains were so
strained in the first place
we are investing critical funding and
expanding domestic manufacturing
including investments of 250 million in
ppe manufacturing
268 million in manufacturing of testing
consumables
14.8 million in vaccine raw material
manufacturing 160 million and fill
finished
65 million in vaccine vial manufacturing
186 million in manufacturing capacity
for at home and point-of-care tests
and 53.8 million in testing raw
materials with additional funds going
out the door every day
i firmly believe that running all this
from dc without the view from the states
and regions is unwise and i've made it a
priority in my first few months to get
out to our regional offices to meet with
those teams and local leaders
and understand the unique challenges
they face
so far i've been to four out of ten
regions with plans to get out to all of
them in the coming months i've met with
an ndms team in new orleans as it was
decompressing a pediatric icu unit this
summer and i have also hosted three
tribal consultations to ensure that
tribal nations and urban indian
organizations are able to access the s s
i'll continue to review analyze and
adjust our response efforts based on
what i'm seeing and hearing in the field
and welcome any feedback you are hearing
from your constituents and singing when
you are home
thank you again for inviting me to
testify before you on efforts within
asper to support the covet 19 response i
look forward to answering your questions
working with the team at asper and our
colleagues across hhs to end the
pandemic thank you
thank you very much to all of our
witnesses we will now begin a round of
five minute questions
of our witnesses i as always ask my
colleagues please keep track of your
clock and stay within those five minutes
the fda's emergency use
authorization of the pfizer vaccine for
children 5 to 11 years old is really a
big step in the pandemic response that
will make 28 million children eligible
to receive a vaccine and given the
spread of variance getting kids
vaccinated is really critical to
protecting them while also protecting
our educators and our parents and other
caregivers dr woodcock i want to ask you
can you describe fda's thorough review
of scientific evidence in making this
decision as well as your advice to
parents who are hesitant to get their
children vaccinated
yes certainly
the fda first reviewed the manufacturing
of a new dosage form because the
children need a lower dose that was very
carefully reviewed as well as the
stability of
the new dose to make sure that it was
appropriate then all the data on
the children were reviewed at the
patient level in other words we went to
the raw data and re-reviewed that and
made sure that the evidence that was
presented to us accurately reflected
both the data on effectiveness on
efficacy on the immune response and on
safety and we looked at all the adverse
events to make sure that they were
properly reported and that we understood
the uh magnitude of those events so
in this trial of thousands where
thousands of children received the
vaccine ages five to eleven um we saw
mostly very mild to moderate uh flu-like
symptoms primarily after vaccine or sore
arm which people can expect after
getting a shot
but we did not see any
serious adverse events
and the vaccine was over 90 percent
protective
so
we feel very confident along with all
the adolescent data that we have on this
vaccine and all the data and and
administration to adults that this
vaccine is safe and appropriate for
children it will protect them from
severe coven
thank you
dr molinski this morning osha
released an emergency temporary standard
to protect workers against coven 19 this
is a critical step to reducing workplace
transmission and making workplaces safer
nationwide especially for our frontline
workers who are at high risk of coven
19. can you just speak to us from a
public health perspective about the
urgent need to get more americans
vaccinated and the importance of
implementing measures to protect people
from infection in higher risk settings
like our workplace yeah thank you so
much
we've had 745 000 deaths from this
disease and we're continuing to have
about 75 000 cases every single day we
know the most disruptive thing in a
workforce is to have a covet outbreak
and to have workers in that workforce
come down with covid infection severe
disease and in some cases death
vaccination as we have seen decreases
your risk of infection by six-fold
decreases your risk of hospitalization
and death by tenfold even during this
delta search so there is absolutely a
public health priority to get people
vaccinated and to continue the important
prevention and mitigation strategies
including masking to keep them safe
thank you thank you um this is a
question for the whole panel and i don't
have much time left but i would use my
chair prerogative to ask all of you
because it's an issue we are all
concerned about um senator burr
mentioned it
and that is the issue of testing
we know diagnostic testing is critical
we've had but we've continued to
experience critical challenges with
testing shortage of rapid tests
not enough locations to get tested
supply chain issues and more so i'd like
to ask all of you quickly to respond
what is your agency doing to make sure
our country is well equipped uh to
handle current and future testing needs
and i will begin with dr wilanski
yes thank you so much so um we are
working with states and jurisdictions to
make sure we can provide technical
assistance on how best to utilize these
tests this is important in the school
districts as well 10 billion dollars in
school districts to utilize testing
we provide technical assistance as to
how to utilize it and peer-to-peer
school to school advice on how best to
utilize the testing program as well as
the hiring of school nurses in order to
use the testing program thank you dr
woodcock
we
have streamlined recently
our standards and approach for
over-the-counter tests so we ex as i
said in my testimony so that we hope
they should get out more quickly we
prioritize testing that there where
there's a public health need which right
now is the over-the-counter test and we
also
try to move very quickly those
manufacturers that can make large
supply of tests because there is still
an unmet need there and so we think
between that we have authorized 11
over-the-counter tests and expect more
to come
between that and
what asper is doing that the supply
should increase rapidly
miss o'connell
thank you chair murray uh we we've
invested three billion dollars in the
last two months on increasing production
and supply of rapid point-of-care and
at-home tests one billion of that
focused exclusively on at-home tests so
we continue to try to get those out we
also through hersa
started a pilot program which would
provide free at-home tests through their
federally qualified health centers so
for those families that aren't able to
afford the tests
in the pharmacies this would allow free
access dr fauci
yes thank you madam chair the
is prioritizing the development of
affordable at-home tests
through a program called the independent
test assessment program
or itap which we will provide
reliable independent laboratory and
clinical test
to the fda
for the manufacturers so that they can
scale up quickly
and if the tests meet the fda's
performance and quality standards the
fda hopefully will then give an
emergency use authorization so we're
providing data
for the companies to be able to expedite
the availability of tests that are rapid
efficient and point of care
thank you i'm senator burke thank you
sherman
this question directed dr fauci and
wolinski in january an nih study found
that 95 of people who had recovered from
covin had at least three out of five
components needed to recognize the virus
up to eight months after infection in
august israeli researchers found that
natural immunity can confer longer
lasting and stronger protections against
infection severe disease and
hospitalization resulting from the delta
variant rockefeller university found
that while vaccination induces memory b
cells to evolve over the course of a few
weeks
natural infection produces memory b
cells that improve for up to one year
after infection this is likely because
remnants of the virus remain in the body
for longer than a vaccine would which
gives the body more time to adapt to it
i understand that it's not all black and
white uk researchers release studies
results suggesting that fully vaccinated
individuals who had covet 19
have the highest
immunity
additionally last week cdc published a
new report that found unvaccinated
people who had previously been infected
were five times more likely to test
positive for covert 19 than people who
were fully vaccinated with an mrna
vaccine
my question is simple
what does the science say about the
durability of natural immunity and when
can we expect answers on its benefit
thank you so much heather burr um the
cdc did publish a 96 page paper review
in a scientific brief on friday
i want to be very clear that the cdc
continues to recommend that people after
review of that scientific brief that cdc
continues to recommend that people who
have been previously infected get their
coven 19 vaccine
we know
in our vaccine studies our vaccine
effectiveness studies with date certain
when people were vaccinated and we can
prospectively follow them through our
effectiveness studies and our
effectiveness cohorts
through that we can see the durability
with a date certain in vaccines
the the data on
the infection-induced immunity some of
which you quoted are murkier they rely
on retrospective studies observational
studies and studies where we can't do a
prospective study we are following these
people we are following people who've
been previously infected in our
infection um cohorts um but the data and
the science are harder you talked about
uh infection-induced immunity with b
cells memory b cells and antibodies but
another arm of the immune system the t
cells
are harder to study and harder to
evaluate in in
to try and do this in a in a commercial
type fashion what i would say is the
final study that you you cited which is
the study from the cdc
that retrospectively looked at a cohort
of people who had been previously
infected and those who had been
previously vaccinated and as you noted
there was a five and a half times fold
more likely chance of being diagnosed
with covid if you had infection induced
rather than vaccine-induced immunity and
that is among the studies that we
reviewed that led to us to our current
recommendations dr falchi
just to add a little bit to that
senator burr
there are studies you refer to were nih
funded studies about
b-cell and t-cell responses by nih
grantees it is true that as a matter of
fact both from natural infection
as well as from vaccine-induced immunity
you have not only antibody responses but
you have the development and the
maturation of memory b cell responses
and t cell responses one of the goals
over the next several months which are
currently being done
by our grantees is to determine the
clinical correlation
between the development and maturation
of b-cell and t-cell responses and
clinical effect and we're looking at
that both post-vaccination
post-boost and in individuals who've
been infected
hopefully we'll get more definitive
information over the next several months
should a individual who has recovered
from covid
be exempt from the mandate to be
vaccinated
given that they have natural immunity
cdc recommendations suggest that you
have more both more durable and robust
and known immune response if you are
vaccinated after you've been previously
infected and those are our
recommendations children 5 to 11 who
have recovered from covid
should they be vaccine exempt
our guidance
continues to recommend that children
who've been previously infected actually
get vaccine we as as we're data are
emerging on
the impact of natural infection
and adults our data are still even
sparser among children
how does the concentration of antibodies
in a recovered covid positive patient
compare
to an individual six months after
they've had a vaccination
it really varies from study to study the
one thing that we do know
that's very important when you talk
about
post-infection immunity is that when you
vaccinate
a person
following recovery from infection
the level of antibodies are considerably
higher
than post-infection alone
and higher than vaccination alone so the
best combination of high degree
of laboratory related protectiveness
is if a person who gets infected and
recovers
ultimately gets vaccinated and that
looks like the most powerful of the
protective responses
clearly i understand that from the data
my question on whether a covet positive
recovered patient should be mandated to
take a vaccine
if they've not had covet
then you take a vaccine to boost your
immunity level to a certain degree
covet positive patients have already
done that
and uh i'm just telling you it's a hard
sale to tell people who have had covet
that they're now under a mandate
mandated by the federal government
to
be vaccinated i think you've got an
extremely
tough sale
to a healthcare professional doctor
nurse who had covet
might have a hesitancy about the vaccine
and i look at what
asper's required to do to fill in for
the health care vacancies that exist out
there and surge people to it
you start doing this to people medicare
medicaid providers
community health centers we're going to
we're not going to have the people to
surge dawn from the health care
professionals that make a decision i had
a natural immunity i've got some
protection but i don't yet believe i
need to be vaccinated
i think we need to think about this
thank you chair
senator kane
thank you chair murray and thank you to
the witnesses the ranking member
i'm going to ask about two topics
supporting the mental health of our
frontline health care workers that has
been such
a challenge in this time and long
covered so to dr wolinski i'll address
you first we've talked about this before
the pandemic has taken a huge toll on
frontline health care workers
this committee has come together in a
bipartisan way to help pass the lorna
green health care provider protection
act passed the senate in august it's
actually being marked up in the house
today the health subcommittee i'm happy
about that we're proud to have worked
together with
folks in this body to get 140 million
dollars of funding
for this initiative in the american
rescue plan
dr williams can we work closely with dr
marine's family for over a year to build
support for the work introduce the
legislation get funding in the american
rescue plan and we're encouraged by
progress that's being made on this
bipartisan initiative
as the cdc works to implement this bill
and use these funds to promote education
and awareness campaigns what can those
of us who have worked on this bill who
care very much about this issue do to
help the cdc effectively communicate
with our frontline healthcare workers
that there are resources and help
available for them
thank you so much senator kane and thank
you so much for your leadership in this
very much needed bill and these
resources um first let me just
give you a sense of the scope of the
challenges and the problems that we face
cdc published a nmwr several weeks ago
not just in healthcare but also in our
public health workforce half of the
people had
half of the people surveyed had more
than one mental health challenge in the
year in the year prior a third reported
depression a third reported anxiety
eight percent of our public health
workforce republi reported suicidal
ideation in the past year
when we talk about our health care
workers yes we're hearing about our
places that are stressed with coveted
surges but we're not hearing about our
public our health care workers who are
left after those surges who are taking
care of people where amputations are
higher higher rates than we've ever had
before missed cancer diagnosis because
of mist of missed care this is what is
impacting our public health our health
care workers and these resources are now
some of these resources are now with
niosh so that we can provide them for
mental health for resources for support
for to to research what it is that they
need so that we can provide this health
care workforce as well as our public
health workforce the the resources that
they desperately need i'm very grateful
thank you thank you um dr fauci on long
coven i've had covet and i'm still
dealing with nerve tingling issues you
know 18 months after having had it
they're they're mild thank goodness but
others who are dealing with long covert
effects they aren't so mild
fatigue respiratory cardiac
other issues what updates can you
provide about nih research
on efforts to better understand the
symptoms of lung covin and how to expand
treatment options for patients who have
this condition
yes thank you very much for that
question senator this is a a very
important problem which we take very
seriously at nih since our last uh
hearing when you also brought up that
very important question
we have now in full implementation of a
program called recover program
which is about a 1.5
billion dollar program
looking at the formation of large
cohorts of individuals to be able to
study them from the standpoint of the
incidence the prevalence and importantly
what the pathogenic mechanisms of
symptoms such as your tingling but even
as you mentioned correctly
so many people have
much more severe in the sense of almost
incapacitating fatigue sleep
abnormalities a variety of other things
there's three components
to the program
that we've just recently awarded one
is a significant amount of resources to
the nyu langone center in new york which
takes
the scientific lead for the program
the data collection will be led by
massachusetts general hospital and
harvard medical school
and the repository for specimens will be
led by mayo clinic
since we last spoke all three of those
have now become operable and hopefully
the next time we speak in a situation
like this i'll be able to give you some
scientific data that resulted from those
studies thank you thank you very much
for that answer i yield back jeremiah
senator paul
dr fauci
i don't expect you today to admit that
you approved of nih funding for gain of
function research in wuhan but your
repeated denials have worn thin and a
majority of americans frankly don't
believe you
even the nih now admits that eco health
alliance did perform experiments in
wuhan that created viruses not found in
nature
that actually did gain in lethality
the facts are clear the nih did fund
gain of function research in wuhan
despite your protestations you can deny
it all you want but even the chinese
authors of the paper in their paper
admit
that viruses not found in nature were
created and yes they gained in
infectivity
your persistent denials though are not
simply a stain on your reputation
but are clear and present danger to the
country and to the world
as professor kevin espelt of mit has
written gain of function research looks
like a gamble that civilization can't
afford to risk
and yet here we are again with you
steadfast in your denials why does it
matter
because gain of function research with
laboratory-created viruses not found in
nature could cause a pandemic even worse
the next time
we're suffering today from one that has
a mortality of approximately one percent
they're experimenting with viruses that
have mortalities of between 15 and 50
percent
yes our civilization could be at risk
from one of these viruses
experiments that combine unknown viruses
with known pandemic-causing viruses are
incredibly risky experiments that
combine unknown viruses with
coronaviruses that have as much as 50
mortality could endanger civilization as
we know it
and here you sit
unwilling to accept any responsibility
for the current pandemic and unwilling
to take any steps to prevent gain of
function research from possibly
unleashing an even more deadly virus
you mislead the public by saying that
the published viruses could not be
coveted well exactly no one is alleging
that no one is alleging that the
published viruses by the chinese are
covered what we are saying is that this
was risky
type of research gain of function
research it was risky to share this with
the
with the chinese and that kovid may have
been created from a not yet revealed
virus we don't anticipate the chinese
are going to reveal the virus if it came
from their lab
you know that but you continue to
mislead you continue to support nih
money going to wuhan you continue to say
you trust the chinese scientist you
appear to have learned nothing from this
pandemic
will you today finally take some
responsibility for funding gain of
function research in wujon
senator with all due respect i disagree
with so many of the things that you've
said
gained first of all gain of function
is a very nebulous term
we have spent not us but outside bodies
a considerable amount of effort
to give a more precise definition to the
type
of research that is of concern
that might lead to a dangerous situation
you are aware of that
that is called
p3co we're aware that you deleted gain
of function from the nih website well i
can get back to that a moment if we have
time
but let's get back to the operating
framework and guidewells of which we
operate under
and you have ignored them
the guidelines are very very clear
that you have to be dealing with a
pathogen that clearly is shown and very
likely to be highly transmissible in an
uncontrollable way
in humans and to have a high degree of
morbidity and mortality and that you do
experiments to enhance that hence the
word e-p-p-p
enhanced pathogens of potentia protect
and caused a recombinant virus that
doesn't exist in nature and it made my
sicker mice that had humanized cells
you're saying that that's not gain of
function research according to the
framework and guidelines so what you're
doing is defining a weigh gain of
function you're simply saying it doesn't
exist because you change the definition
on the nih website this is terrible and
you're you're completely trying to
escape the idea that we should do
something about trying to prevent a
pandemic from leaking from a lab there's
the preponderance of evidence now points
towards this coming from the lab and
what you've done is change the
definition on your website to try to
cover your ass basically that's what
you've done you've changed the website
to try to have a new definition that
doesn't include the risky research
that's going on until you admit that
it's risky we're not going to get
anywhere you have to admit that this
research was risky the nih has now
rebuked them your own agency has rebuked
them
but the thing is is you're still
unwilling to admit that they gained in
function when they say they became
sicker they gained in lethality it's a
new virus that's not gain of function
according to the definition that is
currently operable
you know senator
let's make it clear for the people who
are listening the current definition
was done over a two to three year period
by outside bodies including the nsabb
two conferences by the national academy
of science engineering and medicine
on december 2014
march 2016
we commissioned external risk benefit
assessment
and then on january of 2017
the office of science and technology
policy of the white house
issued the current policy and
coincidence i have no
definition
on the same day the nih said that yes
there was a gain of function in wuhan
the same day the definition appeared the
new definition to try to define a way
what's going on in wuhan until you
accept it until you expect accept
responsibility we're not going to get
anywhere close to trying to prevent
another lab leak of this dangerous sort
of experiment you won't admit that it's
dangerous and for that lack of judgment
i think it's time that you resign thank
you senator paul and i would like um to
give the time to dr patrick yeah well
there were so many things that are
egregious misrepresentation here
uh madam chair that i i don't think i'd
be able to refute all of them but just a
couple of them
for the listens to here for
you has said that i'm unwilling to take
any responsibility for the current
pandemic i have no responsibility for
the current pandemic
the current pandemic okay number two
you said the overwhelming amount of
evidence indicates that's a lab leak
i believe
most card carrying
viral
phylogenies and molecular virologists
would disagree with you
that is much more likely even though we
leave open all possibilities it's much
more likely that this was a natural
occurrence
third you say we contested 80 000
animals
you made a statement just a moment ago
that's completely incorrect
where you say we continue to support
research at the wuhan institute of
virology you approved it in august of
last year no no your statement says
quote i wrote it down as you were
writing you continue to support research
at the wuhan institute of arizona
committee a month ago and said you still
trust the chinese scientist and you
still support the research over there
you said it a month ago and committed i
have allowed dr fauci to respond you've
had your time i'm going to give him he's
going to be dishonest he ought to be
jealous senator paul we will allow dr
fauci to respond after you've given
accusations like that dr fauci well i
don't have any more to say except to say
that as usual and i i have a great deal
of respect
for this body of the senate and it makes
me very uncomfortable to have to say
something but he is egregiously
incorrect in what he says thank you
history will figure that out on its own
we will turn to senator hassan thank you
thank you madam chair and ranking member
burr i want to thank all the witnesses
too for being here today
and for your work i want to start with a
question to assistant secretary
o'connell
last month i sent a letter to health and
human services secretary basara
highlighting the difficulty that some
granite staters have faced in accessing
covid19 rapid tests and urging the
secretary to take action
these tests are essential tools to help
ensure that people can stay safe kids
can stay in school and we can keep our
economy open
so assistant secretary o'connell what
will the department do to address the
issues raised by my constituents in new
hampshire about access to coven 19 rapid
tests
senator hassan thank you so much for the
question and of course thank you for the
letter
um your letter raised two key points one
the amount of time it was taking for
some of your constituents to get the
results and the other was the lack of
the over-the-counter tests in new
hampshire so we responded to both the
asper testing team reached out to the
state health official to understand the
delay
and
learned that the average turnaround time
right now is about 1.1 days
though it sounds like your constituents
had some different experiences we'll
continue to watch that the second issue
was about the lack of over-the-counter
tests the team reached out to abbott and
they have now secured the 60 000 tests
that new hampshire has ordered they will
come in 10 000
increments for six weeks so you should
have 60 thousand tests in new hampshire
by christmas
thank you very much i appreciate that i
know my constituents do too especially
parents of school-aged children who want
to get those results quickly so the kids
can get back into the classroom um dr
fauci
as
i think probably as some colleagues have
already noted uh but i wanted to talk
about the availability of
vaccines for
younger children i think all families in
new hampshire were relieved when the
food and drug administration and the
centers for disease control signed off
on pfizer's covet vaccine for children
ages 5 to 11 last week at a hearing
earlier this year i asked
when you anticipated that vaccines would
be available for children of all ages
and you told me that you thought
vaccines would be ready for children of
any age by the end of the year do you
still anticipate that vaccines will be
available for children under age five by
the end of the year
i don't know when you say available um
senator that that's the difference
between the clinical studies right that
are done to show the data currently
as we are speaking now
the age de-escalation studies are part
of a spectrum one of the spectrum was
what you've just heard of five to 11
the data we're convincing you've heard
of the results from doctors woodcock and
dr wolenski the studies are ongoing now
from six months up to two years two
years to five years right i would
anticipate i would have hoped that the
data might be available by the end of
the year i i would say and again it's
very difficult to make predictions
because you don't want to get ahead of
the data and you don't want to get ahead
of the fda's analysis but you're
thinking i'm just trying to get a sense
of timeline yeah i i would think it
might be towards the beginning of the
coming year or the end of this year i
hope thank you very much uh dr woodcock
i wanted to shift to another issue
because of course while we're dealing
with the pandemic we also continue to
deal with the opioid epidemic i recently
sent you a bipartisan letter about the
consulting firm mckinsey which
simultaneously worked for both opioid
manufacturers such as purdue pharma and
for the fda on a variety of projects
including a track and trace system to
monitor dangerous prescription drugs the
fda response to my letters stated that
mckinsey never disclosed these potential
conflicts of interest and that the fda
only learned about them earlier this
year nearly a decade later through media
reports mckinsey's work for purdue
pharma was made public a major news a
major news story last year and mckinsey
issued a public apology for its actions
last year as well so why wasn't the fda
aware of mckinsey's work for purdue last
year when it was front page news and
mackenzie was speaking publicly about it
well at least speaking for myself i was
aware of that at that time mckenzie was
only
doing consulting work of a
administrative nature for the fda
and so the there was nothing that had to
do with any product or any
uh standard or anything like that
doctor i'm i'm sorry to interrupt but
i'm almost out of time i just want to
point out
that they were consulting on a track and
trace system to monitor dangerous
prescription drugs
that your response to my letter also
says
that since finding out about mckinsey's
work for purdue quote no additional
contract reviews or outreach to mckinsey
has occurred so i will because my time
is about to or has expired i will follow
up with you in the fda it seems to me we
have a major conflict of interest
between mckinsey
work for mckesson and purdue at the same
time it was working for
the fda on track and trace system and
it's something we really have to get to
the bottom of it because i think it
helped fuel the opioid epidemic which
has devastated my state thank
you
thank you senator cox
dr falchi
first let me make clear that i believe
in the efficacy of vaccines
and have encouraged my constituents to
become
vaccinated but i'm hoping you can
explain what appears to be
a contradiction when i look at the data
for
the state of maine
main ranks in the top
five states
in the number of people the percentage
of people who have been vaccinated in
fact
95 percent of those over age 65 have
been fully vaccinated and yet
maine has the 15th highest confirmed
deaths from covid
on a per capita basis
our hospitals are overwhelmed we've seen
a 6
increase in hospitalizations 18
increase in people in the icu
a 37
increase in people
on ventilators recently and well it's
largely individuals who are unvaccinated
there are some that are breakthrough
cases
and all of us know individuals who
despite being fully vaccinated have
experienced covet
can you explain to me why a state that
has done a terrific job in getting
people vaccinated
has
is seeing
this surge
in cases
that is overwhelming our hospitals and
causing
great fear and pain
and loss
well thank you for that question senator
well first of all i think you you did
say something just a moment ago that i
think is part of the explanation
you said that most of them are among
people who are unvaccinated however and
it's quite true
that there are breakthrough infections
because no
vaccine is 100 protective and you will
always get breakthrough infections in
general for the most part
breakthrough infections
for people who have been vaccinated all
other things being equal
are usually less severe don't lead as
much to hospitalizations and don't lead
to as much as death
the data though in general
as was mentioned i think specifically
the numbers that were given by dr
walensky
are incontrovertible
that are vaccinated compared to an
unvaccinated person has a multi-fold
less likelihood of being infected a
multi-fold less likelihood of being
hospitalized or dying so i think there
are probably
confounding multiple factors going into
the difficult situation that your
citizens in your state are going through
but there's no doubt that the vaccines
clearly
much much better in the sense of
protecting you from infection
hospitalizations or death
compared to the unvaccinated
dr walensky
parents teachers and pediatricians have
all talked to me
about the learning laws the emotional
behavioral health programs
problems rather that have occurred
among children
due to their not being in school
and in contrast to the quarantining
option
the test to stay approach
allows asymptomatic students who test
negative for covid
to remain in school
rather than quarantining after another
student or staff member
has tested positive for the virus a
lancet study shows that case rates were
not significantly higher
at schools that use the test and stay
approach
versus schools that require students to
miss school and quarantine at home and
indeed your home state of massachusetts
has adopted a test to stay strategy
brown university professor emily oster
has expressed great frustration with the
cdc as being slow
to take a stronger position in favor of
test this day
asking what evidence are they waiting
for
she says school quarantine should end
and be replaced with tests to stay or
nothing another public
health expert
says simply it's madness to quarantine
school children the cdc policies hinder
learning and provide no meaningful
reduction
in covet transmissions
my question for you
is
why doesn't the cdc issue
guidance or recommendations to encourage
school districts to adopt test and stay
in order to avoid these highly
disruptive quarantines
of students who are asymptomatic and
could be tested
thank you senator um thank you for that
question when when you and i spoke in
this room or in this venue in july we
share the priority of getting our
children back to school i've said it's
the first place that should be open in
the last place the first place that
should be open in the last place to
close
in that context we have studies just
this school year that have demonstrated
that we have 96 of our schools open for
which i'm very pleased and still we have
four percent of schools over a million
children who've been impacted by covid
related outbreaks and those schools have
had to be closed our data also
demonstrate that our prevention measures
have been working and schools that are
practicing their prevention measures
including masking they've been three and
a half times less likely to close
because of a covert related outbreak
than those who
have masked but your question is
important these are new data out of the
uk that have demonstrated this new test
to stay strategy that is a strategy
after a child is exposed in a classroom
that they stay in that classroom with
sequential tests every day every other
day to demonstrate that they are
negative so that they can stay in school
we have updated our frequently asked
questions that this is a promising
practice and we're actually working with
local jurisdictions now to demonstrate
the the domestic data here in the united
states that this practice works it's
safe it's effective it gets our children
back to school and importantly we
recognize that jurisdictions are
actually doing this and other
jurisdictions may want to and in that
context we're doing peer-to-peer
matching of schools that are interested
in doing the test to stay practice and
having them talk to schools that are
also doing it so they they can use the
implementation strategies that a school
has already used so we're actively
studying this so that we can provide the
data on it working and we're actively
encouraging it as a promising practice
thank you thank you thank you senator
smith
uh thank you madam chair and ranking
member and thank you so much to our
panelists for being with us today
so i just want to start by highlighting
that we have made major steps forward in
getting americans vaccinated
vaccine requirements are working i
believe to encourage people to
get these highly effective vaccines
we're also seeing progress with children
it is great news and a big deal that
children
age 5 to 11 can now get their shots so
clearly we have more work to do
but this is progress
so i'd like to spend my time focusing on
the trajectory of this pandemic and what
normal is going to look like going
forward i'm starting out it seems to me
that people thought of covid19 as
something like polio for example where
we could quickly we could develop a
vaccine and then we could control or
even potentially eradicate this disease
now it seems that covid19 will be more
like an influenza an infection that will
recur for the foreseeable future though
hopefully with less and less severity
so dr fauci and dr wolenski can you help
us understand how we should be thinking
about the path of this pandemic over the
next couple of years
dr fauci understanding that
we don't have crystal balls and
this is an unpredictable virus um what
do you think the next six months to two
years are going to look like and do you
expect that covet is going to become
more endemic and less pandemic
as we move forward and what does this
mean for how people are going to be
living their lives
yeah so let me just put a very brief
perspective of it senator when you think
about pandemics you're in the pandemic
phase and then you have a deceleration
phase then you have a control phase then
hopefully you'll have elimination and
maybe eradication i think eradication is
out we've only eradicated one virus in
history for humans in that smallpox
we've eliminated certain infections by
very good vaccination programs such as
eliminating polio from the united states
eliminating measles except for some
pockets of under vaccinated group so
what we're really talking about is
control
and control has a wide bracketemic phase
but it still is interfering with what we
would like to get back to what we used
to know as normal what we hope to get it
is at such a low level
that even though it isn't completely
eliminated it doesn't have a major
impact on public health or on the way we
run our lives we would hope
that as we get people more vaccinated
not only in this country
but throughout the world that the level
of viral dynamics will be so low
i can't predict for you today when that
will be
because as we see we now have a
situation where entering the winter the
good news is we're continuing to come
down
and hopefully we'll go further and
further down but what happens globally
will impact us
so if we get more people vaccinated
globally and more people vaccinated now
hopefully within a reasonable period of
time we will get to that point
where it might occasionally be up and
down in the background but it won't
dominate us the way it's doing right now
thank you for that i appreciate you
bringing in the issue of global
vaccination rates and how that affects
our health here at home and i hope um
i hope madam chair uh that this is a
topic that we can devote a little bit
more time to in this committee because i
think it is very salient to the um
our work to protect americans
dr wolenski let me turn to the question
of data and metrics you and i had a
great discussion last week about what is
the most useful data to track the course
of this pandemic as it evolves and
how difficult it is for people to assess
their own relative risk especially now
that we have a vaccine that provides
such strong protection against serious
disease so dr wolinski in this phase of
the pandemic what are the best metrics
for us to pay attention to for example
um should we be paying more or less
attention to positivity rates case rates
or should we be paying more attention to
breakthrough infections that cause
serious illness and hospitalization
more like we track um influenza
outbreaks for example yeah thank you for
that question for that conversation
earlier this week um i've we've been
thinking a lot about what um an endemic
phase looks like and with the data that
we're needed to collect during that
phase
certainly right now we are collecting
data on cases hospitalizations deaths we
know that not all of our case data is
is uh a hundred percent because not
every uh rapid test is being reported
and importantly as we do with flu we
collect
death data we collect hospitalization
data we absolutely need to know how our
health care systems are doing um and we
absolutely need to know how deadly a
flu season is we also collect data on
influenza like illness what is
presenting and we're currently
presenting collecting data now on
cova-like illness so we are working
towards those metrics of what we need
some of them were already in fact all of
them were already collecting and the
question is what are going to be our
best metrics moving forward um and
probably modeling it on flu the other
metric that i think is critically
important
is vaccination rates and one thing that
we haven't really touched on just in
this conversation but we are absolutely
working on and doing much better is our
race and ethnicity data our equity data
because um if we are not following how
we are doing in these communities with
racial and ethnic minorities we are not
going to understand the impact of this
pandemic on all the communities in this
nation we've actually actively worked on
making sure that those are up to speed
as well thank you well thank you thank
you very much as we move forward i think
it is crucial that we are tracking the
right metrics so that americans have a
useful understanding of relative risk
and better understand the steps that
they can take to limit their own risk
just as you say including these vaccines
that work that are safe and that save
lives thank you
thank you senator braun
thank you madam chair
uh first question will be for dr fauci i
was watching the interchange between you
and senator paul that is always
entertaining
and
i think what i'm interested in today
because it was back on may 26
we had a hearing
and what's happened at the wuhan
institute of virology
you know there's a debate out there and
it's not clear
what happened and the thing i remember
at the tail end of our conversation
because the merits of the case either
way senator paul makes it one way you
make it the other way
equal health comes into play in terms of
what happened there
you know
transparency and you were on record as
saying you like it you love it you
believe in it i pressed you that day
well on something i'll get to in a
moment but
what about releasing all the information
that you do have under your control
because i think as long as
the american public can't see it with
all the mystery surrounding what
happened in terms of its origin
and i think then you said well you could
maybe suggest it to president biden on
declassifying
information uh when it comes to the
subject i'm going to get to in a moment
will you agree
liking transparency to get all of the
information out there as it relates to
the origin so we can all see it here in
the senate across the country
i'm
thank you for that question senator i am
have always been am now and will always
be very very much for total transparency
in everything we do
so
as far as i'm concerned what you're
saying resonates
very strongly with me i do want to make
one point
because it it gets confusing to people
one of the things that's very very clear
irrefutable
that the nih funding of grants in wuhan
and the viruses that were discussed
including the viruses
that senator paul mentioned
would be molecularly impossible to have
resulted in saws cov2
and that sometimes gets conflated when
they talk about your funding research
there
where people can argue about the
definition
of gain of function or not i gave you
the process
whereby that definition was established
but what gets confused and conflated
is that any of the card carrying
molecular virologists will tell you
that notwithstanding the debates about
definitions
the funding by the nih
of the grant
and the viruses that were worked on
could not possibly have turned into sars
kovi 2 because there are evolutionarily
so distant
that nothing anybody could have done
could have done that and i really feel i
need to say that but getting back to
your question i'm all fortunate i'm
talking about so has all the information
period been released that pertains to
that subject because that looks like
it'd be under your control
to do that so is it out there publicly
you know i'm not sure exactly what you
mean by all the information but i can
tell you
anything that is under my control
that is legally able to be released i am
all for 100 releasing i promise you that
well we're going to make sure that all
of that is out there because one of the
most difficult things about this whole
navigation is that there are varying
opinions not everybody is going to agree
with you
um we'd like to see it so we can sort
through it where other experts look at
it and the american public now let's get
back to
uh the whole
housing that we have within our own
departments
josh hawley and i had a bill that passed
by unanimous consent through the senate
to declassify that information and again
you said you were for transparency you
were hesitant about that not being your
bailiwick
is that something you would want to go
on record with to advise the president
to get that declassified so that we can
see it
the american public can see it and that
was discussed and you thought you might
be willing to do it back on may 26th you
want to publicly say do it so senator i
to be quite
honest with you i don't i don't really
know when you say
classified information what information
are you referring to because the nih the
information that we involved with is not
classified at all now this would be
stuff that we hold within our
intelligence departments senators have
been able to look at it uh it's not been
released department of homeland security
that's not not what you house within the
nih and that is you being the main
advisor to the president on this issue
why wouldn't you say declassify it so we
can look at it well i would have to find
out senator when you're talking about
classified information that's certainly
above anything that i do because i want
to reiterate for the record that the nih
does not do any classified anything
everything all 100 senators were for
doing it many of us had the ability to
look at it
you or others
dr wolinski it may be a big deal to do
it real quickly thank you for those uh
answers i got a question about
this is that aimed at dr velensky
what about
uh
the importance of therapeutics
and i asked you this back on may 26th
where is that in the whole
journey in terms of having another tool
and prophylactics as well because
there's a lot all of us acknowledge that
a vaccine was a miracle to get
you're seeing where you're running into
some that simply won't get it it's hard
for me to imagine that you'll vaccine
the rest of the world when do you put
the same amount of enthusiasm on the
other two tripods
of the stand to actually
put every tool in the tool chest aimed
at getting rid of this or at least
treating it
thank you senator i'm absolutely for
using therapeutics but i think they
should be used um after we use
vaccination because vaccination
certainly um we have seen that the
therapeutics that are out there the rem
desophere the dexamethasone um the
malnuparovir is a promising new
therapeutic that dr fauci just mentioned
a few minutes ago all of those would be
after you're infected they prevent they
work to prevent severe disease and death
they're not um foolproof so so
certainly my first tool in the toolbox
would be for vaccination and then of
course we would need testing because
most of these therapeutics actually work
best after you have um especially the
oral one while new piravir work best if
you can give them early so i do think we
need as many tools in this toolbox as
possible um i would also say that the
best public health intervention here
would be vaccines and you've said that
before and thanks for reiterating i just
ask you to put that same enthusiasm and
speed behind the other things that
might be out there to help us thank you
thank you um i'm going to go vote as the
senators know a vote is open the next
two senators will be senator murphy and
senator murkowski i hope to be back by
the end of that
thank you very much madam chair thank
you to all of you for your service to
this country during an incredibly trying
time
uh i um thought that senator collins
line of questioning deserved a follow-up
um
she asks a good question she says we've
got high vaccination rates in maine and
so why do we still have so many deaths
um but i think it's important to sort of
step back and look at the national data
here i'll direct this to you dr wilinski
i was looking
at a survey of national data that was
published now back in the spring so it's
a few months old but in it it suggested
that if you look at the 10 states with
the lowest rates of vaccination versus
the 10 states with the highest rates of
vaccination
it's black and white
you are
four times more likely to be
hospitalized if you live in one of those
states with the lowest rates of
vaccination you are five times more
likely to die if you live in those
states and so you know each individual
senator will have their own experience
but tell us what the story is now that
we have lots of variation amongst states
when it comes to vaccination rates and
what that tells us about your likelihood
to ultimately end up in the hospital or
end up dying from from covid um thank
you for that question senator
so yes we have about 75 000 cases a day
right now and there are places there are
states that are highly vaccinated and
they're still having cases that senator
collins has commented on this is going
to be very local very community based
this virus is an opportunist it is
rapidly uh transmissible and if you have
communities that are under vaccinated
even if a state averages at 70 percent
this virus is going to go to those
communities importantly um we have
actually looked during the delta surge
at three states with high vaccination
rates connecticut being one of them and
three states with lower vaccination
rates and we can see even just in this
delta surge just since june that the
death rates in the under vaccinated
states in the states with vaccination
rates that are 10 20 lower than the
highly vaccinated states the death rates
are five to ten fold higher um so we
absolutely can see the impact of this
there are cases that occur in vaccinated
people they for the most part don't lead
to death sometimes they do but for the
most part they don't these vaccines are
preventing disease they are preventing
tenfold more likely to be hospitalized
if you're
unvaccinated versus vaccinated
elevenfold more likely to die if you're
unvaccinated versus vaccinated i think
senator collins question was was was a
good one um and i'm glad to
get the true story of what the
overall national data is here because
it's compelling
but there are other senators
who are deliberately trading in just
dangerously false information it's
stunning that the misinformation about
kovitt is not just coming from purveyors
of propaganda online it is often coming
from our colleagues here in the senate i
was on the floor a few weeks ago
listening to senator johnson
who
suggested pretty
sort of transparently that there was a
correlation between those who got
vaccinated and
post-vaccination deaths um noting that
um
5 000 deaths that were reported on the
adverse event system happened one or two
or three days following a vaccination
suggesting that there was a correlation
um so uh
doctor i'll ask this is dr wolenski
is there
any increased risk of death to
individuals who get a vaccine is there
any data to back up the claim that
senator johnson was making that there's
some correlation between risk of death
and vaccination isn't it exactly the
opposite
for covert it is in fact exactly the
opposite our vaccine adverse event
system um collects all deaths after
vaccination that means if you were
hit in a motor vehicle accident and
succumbed to that event that would be
reported in our vaccine safety system
clearly that is not a causal effect from
a vaccine and yes these vaccines are
working to prevent death um from covet
19 and what i would just say when when
people ask me all the time what they can
do what congress can do what senators
can do for us as a country for me at the
cdc it is to encourage your constituents
to get vaccinated thank you
one of the things i hope this committee
will work on
in the middle of this pandemic and
following is health literacy uh is
helping americans understand where good
sources of medical information are
and where the dark spots are where
you're listening to political actors who
have their own agenda not one based in
science and i think this is frankly a
place where republicans and democrats
can collaborate because i think we have
found a general lack of health literacy
during this pandemic but it was a
problem that existed beforehand
and so well it pains me to know that
some of our colleagues are the purveyors
of this this misinformation it's a
project that probably should be able to
be bipartisan moving forward i
appreciate you all being here thank you
mr chair
senator romney
thank you mr chairman i appreciate your
service and the information you're
providing this morning
just following up on senator murphy's
question
there is a perception that side effects
adverse effects from the vaccine
are not being gathered that they're not
being
made available to the public
are the side effects and adverse effects
dr walinski
being captured are they available to the
public is there a place we can go to see
what the likelihood
is of various side effects based upon
getting a a vaccine
we have the most robust vaccine safety
system than we have ever had in this
country in the role out of that this
vaccine our vaccine adverse events
reporting system as senator murphy just
described has over six hundred thousand
reports publicly available we have a new
v-safe system which is developed
specifically for the cova 19 vaccine
program it uses a text message system
web surveys to get people to provide
their symptoms after they've been
vaccinated it includes over nine and a
half million people and over 12 and a
half 12 million health surveys we have a
pregnancy registry where we
survey pregnant women we are are getting
their information during their vaccine
after their vaccine in their first
trimester we call them in their second
trimester their third trimester after
their baby is born and at three months
we've registered over um 5 000 women in
that and we have over 25 24 000 who have
been contacted and we have a vaccine
safety data link which is a
collaboration with our academic
institutions which includes over seven
and a half million people who initiated
vaccinations this is the most robust
vaccine safety system that has that's
ever been documented and where might the
public go to see what the probability is
of various side effects or adverse
effects from the vaccination
on our cdc website thank you appreciate
that
dr fauci a number of us are concerned
about mandates obviously um
the question and i
sent you a text just to prep you for the
question but the question in this regard
is um
if we do have a mandate
and i'm thinking now of the mandate for
private companies if we do have a
mandate
will it save lives and is there an
estimate of of the number of lives that
might be saved by virtue of having our
uh private companies that have over 100
employees either having their employees
receive a vaccination or get a weekly
test if if that occurs will it save
lives and you have an estimate of the
number of lives it might save
i have a very firm and confident answer
to your first question senator and i
don't have one of your second but let me
just explain very briefly
we know that vaccines absolutely save
lives
and we know that mandates work
if you look at for example the
percentage of people in united airlines
or in the houston medical association or
in other organizations that have
mandated it works 99 plus percent for
example with united airlines so if you
take the fact that mandates work
and vaccines absolutely save lives the
answer to your question is yes it does
save lives how what that number is you'd
have to do modeling center that i don't
have in front of me right now to
determine when people get vaccinated in
a certain area what is the chance of
their having gotten infected and given
their underlying condition what's the
chances of their having died or not that
information can likely be modeled but i
don't have that for you right now yeah i
i would think that given the information
you do have if you extrapolate from the
information you have as to where
mandates have been imposed such as
united airlines
and and you apply it you can calculate
what the number of lives say might be i
would think that would be helpful for me
and for others who are
concerned about mandates uh we're also
concerned about lives lost and
protecting human life um
we also had a question from senator uh
kane about the uh the long haulers if
you will the long covid uh
how serious are these long uh uh
hall uh cases uh and uh uh and and uh uh
what proportion of those that that have
cove do you have a sense do we know the
number what proportion of those that
ever that have had covet are subject to
if you will serious uh long covet
conditions
a very good question senator that we are
now actually finding out more definitive
data there have been a number of
published papers from different smaller
cohorts
we're now putting a massive cohort study
and among the smaller cohorts it ranges
from 10 to up to 30 35
of people
have varying degrees
of prolonged symptomatology following
the so-called resolution of the acute
disease
some of them can be relatively minor but
some of them can be incapacitating for
example there are some individuals who
have truly incapacitating fatigue where
they were pretty healthy athletic and
then following covert they never get
back to their baseline there are sleep
disturbances they're a thing called
brain fog
which can be very disturbing to people
where they can't focus or concentrate so
the spectrum is wide it can go from
something that just is modestly bearable
to something that incapacitates you and
that's the reason why we have this study
right now looking at it that's about a
1.5 billion dollar investment to try and
sort that out i i would just note i know
my time is up but i would just note that
it would be helpful for those of us that
are concerned about our children or
grandchildren to have a sense not just
of the number of deaths associated with
with covid in in children but also the
number of long covid cases severe long
coveted cases because it would be my
estimate that that probably
substantially exceeds
the number of deaths among young people
and that information i think would be
helpful for parents and grandparents
like myself thank you
senator hickenlooper
there we go sorry about that uh once
again i want to thank each of you for
your
not just for
your testimony today but for all the
work you have done over
this entire
and it is a campaign it's it's it's very
similar to a war we're seeing a covid
surge right now in colorado that
has led to emergency capacity issues in
our hospitals
and that's not just in certain parts
pretty much across the state
just about 80 percent of those in the
hospitals are unvaccinated
and dr faucia
i guess
this my question my first question to
you in a state like colorado where we
have made real progress i mean great
strides in vaccination rates
um
how should we be thinking about this
recent surge just that it's still it's
still the tail of the of the
unvaccinated yeah
yeah
that is not unexpected when you get into
for example the situation where the
weather starts to get colder and people
do things more indoor but as you said
quite correctly
when you see surges they are very very
heavily weighted towards the
unvaccinated not only in the incidence
of infection
but also in the incidence of severe
disease that might lead to
hospitalization i believe that's a
pretty obvious type of an explanation
for that which is the reason why
we continue to push to get as many
people vaccinated as we possibly can
right
uh and dr wolinski
uh
i thought that uh senator romney's
comments about
his children and grandchildren
and i think soon if not already his
great-grandchildren
that is an issue that's what we're
seeing more questions every day um
and so the
this week's vaccine approval for five to
eleven year olds
um
uh
i think one question we've heard is is
how is that going to affect this this
rising
this increase in in um
infection rates uh how are we going to
be
how how do we do everything we can to
make sure these kids get vaccinated of
those who want to be vaccinated
yeah so thank you senator um first let
me go back to senator romney's question
on percent of children who get long
coveted we've had about 1.9 million
children between the ages of five to 11
we've seen a long covet rate in those
children of about four and a half
percent it's less than adults but it's
still high and it's still we should note
it we've also seen in that demographic 5
000 cases of misc that's multi-system
inflammatory syndrome that can be
devastating we've had 46 deaths from
misc alone and nearly 100 children in
the demographic between ages 5 to 11.
we have a lot of work to do to reach out
to our pediatricians to reach out to our
parents to make sure that we have the
communication the education the
information that parents need
this is a new vaccine to them they've
perhaps received the same pfizer vaccine
themselves but for their children it's a
new vaccine one thing i think is really
important and is probably worth
grounding people on is we have a lot of
vaccine preventable diseases for our
children now varicella hepatitis a
meningococcus just to name a few the the
death rates from varicella are about 16
per year before vaccination for
hepatitis a about 33 per year from
meningitis meningococcus about eight per
year the death rate for covet in this
age demographic was 66.
wow
very sobering i am fully aware of the
of the high levels on vaccinated kids in
certain
uh especially in certain geographic
areas my my son teddy who's now off at
college but when he was had just turned
four months he was about to get a second
whooping cough shot
and he got infected by a uh
unvaccinated kid who
uh we were
well it's
about the most terrified
it's the most terrifying experience i
think i've ever been in
where you just can't stop him from
coughing and you're in a a hospital and
you have to blow oxygen on his face
uh to try and
just shake him out of the coughing and
absolutely terrifying
uh and it was amazing it took us a long
time to get a doctor to diagnose it
because at that point we were just
beginning to see whooping cough again
because everyone had gotten back was in
the habit of getting their children
vaccinated and suddenly that changed
ms o'connell um
i also worry that the uh recent
uh surge is further stretching
the the situations around our front line
workers
um after already the last couple years
tremendously difficult
we hear that in colorado and
is that happening across the country as
well
senator yes thank you for that question
we have sent
27 different teams out to augment
hospitals that were overrun by covid
patients
about 600 team members to 12 different
states so we are seeing that
great and how do we address burnout
among health care workers how what
advice can can you provide
well we've been happy of course to go in
and help where we can but we know that
we're not the sustainment
and
one of the things that the american
rescue plan provided was funding for
the public health workforce and so we're
continuing to look for ways to invest in
a long-term public health workforce
to support these
first responders and healthcare workers
that are burned out and worn out from
this pandemic
well again i'll just finish by saying
thank you to each of you
one of the most amazing things to me is
as a scientist
who recognizes the importance of data
that your your ability and your your
your vision to start collecting data
from the very beginning and make sure
that we take
the lessons that we learn in this
situation where so often people are
making decisions without enough data
is really going to inform our pandemic
preparedness uh and help this not just
our country but the world as we go
forward and battle not just this this
virus but the others to come thank you
thank you
senator chubberville
thank you very much
madam chair thank you for being here
today
uh no it's hard work uh and you need to
get back to work
you know my former job
you know i had to win games and uh
in your business we gotta win and right
now we're not winning uh john hopkins
university
i just made a report last week that uh
this year we've lost
353 000 people
and uh
to this point last year that's how much
we we lost the entire year
uh
it's a little perplexing that you know
we've got two vaccines boosters and
we've got masks and all that we we still
got to win uh we got we got to win this
fight i mean i think everybody
understands that you know i recently
wrote an op-ed talking about how we need
an all-above approach
we need every tool in the toolbox to be
used been talking to doctors all over
alabama we've had a tough problem
they are very upset that they don't have
the freedom
to treat like they should have the
freedom to treat uh they're being told
by officials in their hospital that they
can't use certain drugs such as
ivermectin or whatever
and they know that it works that's what
they tell me i'm not a doctor
monoclonal antibodies we ran out in
alabama because for some reason we're
starting to ration those in the last few
months and i think i could ask all of
you what you think about monoclonal
antibodies and i think you'd all say
they to some degree they work
uh
but this specific question is for ms
o'connell i want to ask you this you
know congress gave money through the
cares act
to help with development of production
of therapeutics
within three months of being in office
president bison's administration decided
not to buy
or they declined to exercise contract
options on monoclonal antibodies and i
know you weren't there at the time
they inherited these contracts from the
trump administration those decisions
caused a shortage especially for us in
in alabama at the same time
the by administration was ramping up
monoclonal production
uh
as we're trying to get back to it hhs
turned and gave a 142 million dollar
non-compete contract to an accounting
firm to market these treatments to the
public
the administration hired kpmg to promote
a therapeutic
that the
government stopped buying that makes no
sense i looked at the
the website and and uh
my son and i could probably put it
together for ten thousand dollars we
paid 142 million uh so i'm just asked
you and miss mcconnell i understand that
uh
hhs is currently reviewing this uh i
just would hope that uh you would commit
to reprogramming some of that money to
monoclonals
if
there's any left could i get a
commitment on you for that
senator thank you so much for the
question um we have seen a change in the
monoclonal landscape when the
asper
therapeutics team began looking at the
distribution models in february a lot
different
than we experienced during the delta
surge
20-fold increase in demand for
monoclonals
and we went to a state distribution
system
and so you're absolutely right it's time
to reevaluate whether we need uh this
distribution help to get to the harder
hit communities and that review is
underway right now i'm expecting a memo
any day with the team's recommendations
uh on whether to keep that funding going
thank you and you know we just need to
get more of them i know we're trying to
do that and we're all trying to do our
best but uh you know we just got to try
to do it the right way dr fauci you talk
a lot about gain of function research
and whether or not u.s funded it i'm not
a doctor i'm not a scientist so i'm not
gonna i'm gonna just ask you straight
forward here you know what kind of
biological research is china actually
conducting as we speak uh that we know
of
yeah
well right now when you say china china
is well beyond the wuhan situation
there's
uh research that goes on collaboratively
with the united states not only with nih
but with any of a number of
organizations including the cdc
where we have chinese researchers uh the
funding
that goes on right now that was just
mentioned with dr paul we are not
funding the wuhan institute anymore
that's for sure um but i can't testify
to
the scope of research that goes on
beyond what the nih so the wa show they
don't they don't commun uh communicate
with us because we're paying them for
hundred million dollars yeah surely the
goodness they have something to do with
what china's doing
for the most part the research that
comes out of china if you look at the
things over the years i'm talking not in
this capsule of period where it's all
focused on china anti-china i'm talking
about decades of collaboration
particularly in the arena of influenza
and other diseases there's a lot of
research going on i don't think i can
tell you what all the research is going
on because i don't have eyes on all the
research the only thing communicating
with them though
somehow someone with china
well yeah we communicate a lot with them
uh certainly there's been a lot of
stress and strain right now when you
talk about the wuhan situation but our
colleagues in shanghai our colleagues in
beijing we communicate with them all the
time the chinese have a very very fine
centers for disease control and
prevention modeled against our own cdc
and our cdc is in very good
collaboration and cooperation with them
i just think that they'd let us in early
that we may have not been in this
situation maybe the world in this
situation that we're in i hope you would
agree with that and they just kind of
shut us off no absolutely and we want to
find all the information we can and the
nih and the entire hhs
has been very much in favor of all
transparency and getting to know all the
information of what's going on in china
we're all very much in favor of that we
want more transparency thank you thank
you senator casey
murray thank you
would ask
first consent unanimous consent that the
statement from the alzheimer's
association and alzheimer's impact
movement be submitted for the record
without objection
thank you chair murray i wanted to start
with assistant secretary o'connell
about in particular the hospital
preparedness program it's a program i've
long
supported um
aggressively and and and so many others
have as well
for those listening this is a program
that supports hospitals and other
healthcare facilities and the providers
who work at those facilities in
preparing for public health emergencies
as we all know covet 19 has taxed the
health care system like never before and
at various points in the pandemic as
surges
have hit communities across the nation
at different times
these hospitals and
icus have been overrun with
patients most recently as a result of
the delta variant so
assistant secretary o'connell i've got
three questions first
what role have the local
health care coalitions
which are the core element of the
program one of those coalitions played
in responding to the surges and hospital
admissions
senator thank you so much for that
question and you're absolutely right the
hpp program that you referenced is the
only federally funded program to help
health care systems and hospitals
prepare for emergencies so it's critical
and we've seen it play a significant
role in this pandemic response
the local coalitions were very important
because as we were seeing hospitals
overrun with covid patients they were
able to work with their coalition
members to move patients to
icu's that actually had beds so we did
see that
play a significant important role
second question is are you planning any
after action review
to incorporate lessons learned from the
pandemic
with regard to that the hospital
preparedness program
absolutely senator one of the things as
i've been out in the regions meeting
with local leaders and coalition leaders
i've seen there's been an uneven
use and success of the hpp program uh
based on regional strengths you know
based on state situations and so i think
one of the things i'd like to do as we
look at lessons learned is figure out
how to have a more uniform successful
model for the hpp program
and how about the third question how
about goals for the the
program
in the near term
well a couple of things that we've
learned in the near term the need to
secure ppe within health care systems
and coalitions we've also learned the
value of telehealth and how important it
was for systems to be ready to do some
care remotely so we're going to take
these near-term goals and begin applying
them for longer-term
preparedness i appreciate that those
answers i wanted to move to dr wolinski
on on a broader question i guess about
public health infrastructure
one of the challenges in the response
has been building the systems that we
need to
track information necessary to
manage everything from hospital capacity
and
icu bed availability to critical medical
supplies vaccine components you know the
the long list that that is the concern
of course is that we're going to reach a
point where we
uh we all start saying the pandemic's
over and and we move on
we've got to
finally at long last
invest in our
public health infrastructure how would
you leverage um any
uh tool that we have now especially the
the existing data systems
uh that's been created for kova 19 to
ensure that we're prepared for
the next major public health emergency
yes thank you so much for that question
senator casey my hope and i'm grateful
for the support to date for long-term
disease agnostic public health
infrastructure investments that are
bipartisan so that we don't find
ourselves in a situation again we need
to be prepared for this for any pandemic
to come and we need to get out of the
current pandemic
as you know this is multi-pronged in my
view we need a public health workforce
that is upskilled that is trained that
is diverse as the communities they from
which they come
we have lost 60 000 jobs in the last
decade and thousands more since the
pandemic started so we not only have to
work to rebuild that public health
workforce but actually to skill it up in
ways that can be
empowered to to prevent the next
pandemic laboratory infrastructure is
going to be key we've built up genomic
sequencing now we're doing tens of
thousands a week this was something that
we weren't even doing much of um prior
to the beginning of this pandemic but we
again need the workforce we need the
machinery we need the tools and the
collaborations with our public health
labs
in order to place these all across the
country and then of course you know data
monetization we absolutely need
interoperable data we've been able to
scale this up enormously over the last
year during this pandemic
we have tens of thousands of electronic
health records that we're now accessing
um in a hipaa compliant way where we
were doing just a hundred
before the this pandemic it needs to be
interoperable and we need to invest in
it we um you know to get a full-scale
hospital system up on epic for example
is over a billion dollars for a single
health system so when we scale that
nationally to what we need for our
public health workforces across all of
our states and territories and tribes
and localities um this this is we the
investment is so very needed thank you
thank you thank you thank you madam
chair thank you senator cassidy thank
you all for being here dr olinsky
a couple things as i walked in i came in
late one of either you and dr fauci was
saying that the reason that we're not
saying that natural immunity is
protective as is a vaccine even though
there's recent publications showing that
six to eight months out 92 percent of
those with natural immunity
have t cells b cells and antibodies that
would be considered adequate to protect
and indeed b cell continues to climb
that we don't have data
now in your response to mr casey you
just mentioned that cdc has access to
tens of thousands
of ehrs
and i've been told that hhs or cdc has
access to
patient identifiable data as to who
test positive
so i do that as a prologue
if we don't know
that natural immunity confers
protection against future infection
it's because we've decided not to look
because i've learned that there is a
cohort of people that we know have been
previously infected
we've got the bench research showing
that the
triad of antibodies t cells and b cells
are there
and that 92 percent of them are still
there at age at six months out so why
don't we why have we not done the
research showing that natural immunity
infers protection against recurrent
infection yeah thank you so much for
allowing me to clarify this point
because i understand i understand the
question um first of all let me just
reiterate that our current stand after
reviewing 96 papers and the scientific
brief on this issue is that everyone
who's been previously infected should be
vaccinated but that's not my question
right i agree so so and part of the
challenge here is as you know the
infection-induced immunity and the
biases associated with retrospectively
looking at the data several of those
papers that we reviewed for that brief
have demonstrated that the kind of
disease that you had at the time you had
it matters um did you have disease a
year and a half ago did you have were
you and older can i stop before you we
could do this prospectively
because you know who is actually
apparently i'm told you've got patient
identifiable data
and you would be able to say okay six
months ago we're going to start
everybody infected within the last six
months and be able to follow their ehr
prospectively to see this i mean
theoretically cdc has the ability to do
this right now yet that too would have
its own biases so one of the things that
we have demonstrated in the scientific
brief is that asymptomatic and mildly
symptomatic people who might not present
to their providers might present to an
urgent care clinic who might not be
recorded in their own ehr
likely have less robust protection than
those who've been supportive that could
be established prospectively if using
the data that you have and you could
even say if you had symptomatic
infection you don't need to be
vaccinated we would consider you immune
you don't have to be subjected to the
mandate but if we had data if we had
data that demonstrated a correlation of
protection dr falchi already mentioned
data that they're working on to look at
correlates of protection not just in
antibodies but as you noted in t cell
function as well so if we were able to
document a correlate of protection we
absolutely could but this paper that i'm
reading from cd from nih
speaks that there is durable memory of
the virus up to eight months after
infection and 95 percent of the people
who recovered including b cells which
continue to climb t cells in antibody
and i'm also saying you could do it
clinically because we have data that's
patient identifiable that we could go
back and look and see if they were
exposed they could be in a hot spot like
louisiana where you know they're being
exposed and then you would see not just
by lab data but empirically
i can tell you the american people
intuitively understand this and they
feel a little bit like we're being
willfully blind to it i have limited
time let me just ask you something else
what percent of cdc
employees
are vaccinated
we're actively encouraging vaccination
in all of our employees and doing a lot
of education and outreach in order to
get our agency fully vaccinated and the
but the percent i i don't have that for
you today i'm told that 75 to
some north of 75 percent of cdc
employees at headquarters are still
working remotely
is that correct
um we are following
regulations through hhs and the federal
government no that's not my question
i apologize to be rude but but but i'm
asking a very straightforward question
i've been told that north of 75 percent
of employees that
at cdc headquarters are working remotely
is that correct senator i don't actually
know the number off the topic when you
look down the hallway are there empty
desks are over 50 of the desk
empty
senator i don't have the numbers off the
top of my head what i will tell you is
that we're working closely within hhs in
the administration to follow the
governmental rules for return there was
a recent gao report that shows in the
release in the last two weeks that
there's been no coordinated response on
the federal government to get people
back into work
now if there's any agency that since we
have teachers in fulton county are back
at work that the caseload of covid in
fulton county is about 88 at its peak it
was 606
if what i've been told
by someone who frankly kind of knows
that people in laboratories are not
showing up i have no clue how people how
laboratory workers who presumably are
vaccinated wearing ppe
would consider themselves eligible to
stay at home
i say this because i just want to echo
we got to lead by example in the federal
government if our public health agencies
don't have enough confidence in the
immunization and the ppe to go back to
work fighting infectious diseases
there's going to be a lot of undermining
of an of a willingness to further fund
public health
we absolutely have our essential labs
back at work
conducting their essential research
towards this response and um
we are following the regulations and
providing technical assistance and
technical
support to the federal government for
return to work policies uh one more
thing i had angus king and i had sent a
letter dated february the 25th asking
about genomic surveillance we've still
not received a response you reference it
in your early remarks both senator king
and i would appreciate a response we'll
get back to you thank you very much
thank you are you thank you
i'm going to go vote the next four
centers i have in my order are senator
baldwin marshall rosen and murkowski i
will return
thank you madam chair so we're here
today to discuss the road ahead on the
pandemic response and i
fear that that road will be a rocky one
if we forget the lessons that we've
learned thus far
particularly when it comes to our
ability to make critical supplies like
ppe
in this country
a new york times headline this summer
declared
i quote a glut of chinese masks is
driving us companies out of business
in response i joined several of my
colleagues in writing to the u.s trade
representative catherine tai
to urge her to let tariff exclusions on
chinese ppe expire
the us
trade representative is currently
weighing that decision
one reason these
chinese masks may be so cheap is that
they are counterfeit
some of them
in fact the fda has pulled emergency use
authorizations from several chinese mass
manufacturers
so i'm pleased that asper plans to use
the defense production act funds to
procure masks and the raw melt-blown
material needed to make n95s from
domestic sources
i work to include that funding in the
american rescue plan
however government procurement can only
support so much american industry to
retain a strong base of medical supply
manufacturers and to reduce our reliance
on foreign manufacturers as a whole we
need to prevent
dumped
and knock off
chinese ppe from driving american
manufacturers out of business as well so
first ms o'connell are you concerned
about the practice of dumping
ppe
from china undermining the ability of
domestic manufacturers to remain
competitive in the u.s and if so have
you conveyed these concerns to the u.s
trade representative
senator baldwin thank you so much for
this important question we do
participate in an interagency process
where
various departments have had the
opportunity to share
our
support so yes we we have conveyed
okay uh dr woodcock the fda has revoked
authorizations for certain chinese masks
are you concerned that increased
reliance on chinese ppe will threaten
the safety of u.s health care workers
and if so have you conveyed that concern
to the u.s trade representative
yeah well i can't answer the last part
of your question i don't know i will
look into the u.s trade representative
we are concerned about lower quality
ppe coming from anywhere and we have of
course
put in import alerts we have chased down
and
identified suppliers who have sent in
counterfeits we have tried to do recalls
throughout the united states to get
these off the market
we are interested in increased
authorities because we do not have
seizure authority for devices
and several other authorities that we
have been talking to
staff about
that would improve our ability to
interdict
these counterfeits
thank you um
for dr walensky
throughout the pandemic we've heard
about how gaps in the clinical and
public health workforce have
significantly
hampered our response in particular
we've long faced significant recruitment
and retention issues among infectious
disease clinical uh workforce
and with health professionals who
conduct outbreak preparedness and
response activities
as this committee considers policies to
better prepare for the next pandemic i'm
working to introduce the bio
preparedness workforce act with senators
colin collins rosen and murkowski which
would create a new provider loan
repayment program focused on encouraging
students to pursue careers as infectious
disease clinicians and bio preparedness
professionals dr wolinski as an
infectious disease physician and public
health leader i know that this issue is
particularly important to you
and can you share your perspective on
some of the serious workforce challenges
i mentioned and how proposals to bolster
this workforce might make a difference
in responding to future outbreaks
thank you so much for those efforts for
your support and for that question
we know that about 80 percent of people
leave medical school now
with debt about half of those actually
have undergraduate debt as well and the
debt for an average medical student is
about 215 000
in terms of going into the field of
infectious diseases it is one of the
lowest paying fields for all of medicine
all the subspecialties in fact in most
hospitals if you are an infectious
disease provider versus a generalist
your salary is less as a infectious
disease provider if we are going to
bolster the public health workforce with
infectious disease physicians this this
kind of support will be essential
thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
for being here this afternoon or this
morning
um
11th hearing this is the 11th hearing
that this committee has had on the covid
pandemic
um we had all of course hope that we
would be well beyond this but instead we
are well in the middle of it and we see
it it changing i talk to folks back home
and they really wonder
aloud and what is what's the path out
of of this right now my state is we
we're four times the
the national average in terms of
of number of positive cases uh our
hospitals are still overwhelmed for the
past month we have been
uh we've been number one in the country
nobody wants to be number one here um
and we're going into the winter season
so it's kind of discouraging right now
so we've talked about the the strength
of the vaccines that have been developed
through operation warp speed but i think
everyone would acknowledge that the
pandemic that we encountered in march of
2020 is is different than where we find
ourselves today with the delta virus
variant
we're talking about vaccine hesitancy
very very real in my state we still
don't have a highly effective vaccine
that is stable without refrigeration or
a nasal or an oral vaccination option
i'm i'm worried
that
we're prioritizing vaccine technology
that may not necessarily be feasible
to bring this pandemic to a close
globally
and so a question to you dr fauci and
then to you dr woodcock
do you think dr fauci that what we have
today the existing vaccine technology
that's currently authorized by fda
is is truly sufficient to bring us out
of of this pandemic not just the united
states but globally
and and and what then is the
administration doing to support
and to accelerate development of of the
next phase of vaccines that could offer
longer and broader immunity to the covid
19 and of course all of its variants
thank you for that question senator so
first the vaccines that are currently
available particularly the ease of use
of the mrna and the extraordinary
effectiveness of both the modern and the
fisa rna
are if properly utilized we believe
would
have a much much better control of this
outbreak as we have right now but to
your specific question
we are also supporting the development
of other platforms of vaccines for
example
the soluble protein recombinant protein
together with an adjuvant is something
that traditionally has been vaccines
that have used in other diseases and
have much less stringent requirements
for cold chain
and other things that might logistically
get in the way of getting it more widely
distributed so in specific answer to
your question even though we have very
effective and very safe vaccines that
are being implemented now
we're not stopping there we're making
investments in the development of other
platforms some of them are already well
on their way
but i think it's important to hear that
because i think part of what we're
dealing with with this vaccine hesitancy
is as people are saying well okay you
got your vaccine and believe me i got my
vaccine and i got my second vaccine and
i've now gotten my booster and i'm
hearing from people that are are much
more hesitant than i it's like well if
you're going to have to keep getting one
of these every six months how really
effective is that so dr woodcock let me
ask you i've spoken to some researchers
that are working on these next
generation of vaccines they've told me
that fda is not prioritizing
new vaccine technologies now but rather
they're focusing on therapeutics and
existing vaccines is this accurate and
and can you speak
to that
well the group that regulates
therapeutics is different than the group
that regulates vaccines within the fda
so those they're not competing with each
other right as far as vaccines we have
been prioritizing the ones we could get
out immediately because of the public
health
emergency however
i think there will be new forms of
vaccines as dr fauci said there may be
new vaccines
that
don't require the cold chain they may
manufacturers may be able to modify the
current vaccines to what are called a
lyophilized
formulation that doesn't require
refrigeration that would be good and
people are looking at
different types of vaccines such as oral
nasal and so forth it's just taking
longer i don't think the fda's not
standing in the way of that development
it is the fact that um the tried and
true platforms are easier to get a new
vaccine up and running and we had to do
that in the middle of this emergency to
get things done as quickly as possible
but certainly there's a lot of research
going on in additional vaccines and fda
is not impeding that
mr chairman i have additional questions
that i'll i'll submit to the record i i
would certainly hope that um we're going
to have an opportunity to hear a little
bit more from the administration though
about
um
the the mandates that uh that have been
put in place this newly released
uh emergency temporary standard from
osha
um i think these are these are areas
where when we're talking about vaccine
and vaccine hesitancy we need to be
talking to those who are putting in
place some of these standards that in my
state
are causing an extraordinary issue and
problem within our workforce senator
rose
uh thank you chairper and uh of course
jared murray and ranking member birth
thank you and i want to thank everyone
for being here today and for your
lifelong commitment to saving lives and
protecting us it is something that
people don't realize as you go into
these careers
what the motivation is and i thank you
for that i want to talk a little bit
today about the supply chain because as
we've seen throughout the pandemic
american our reliance on just in time
supply chain for essential goods
especially emergency medical supplies it
really leaves us vulnerable
to critical shortages when we were
experiencing acute shortages of
essential supplies like masks and gowns
many small manufacturers in the united
states while they stepped up to change
what they were producing to meet this
public need like polar shade a las vegas
company that switched from making window
coverings uh to ppe during the crisis
my office heard from a number of
companies looking for federal guidance
to receive technical assistance on
quality standards where the essential
goods were needed most but there was no
system in place to handle this type of
situation that's why i introduced with
senator cassidy the bipartisan strategic
planning for emergency medical
manufacturing act it's going to create a
voluntary domestic backup manufacturing
network a process for manufacturers to
plan ahead
prepare receive this guidance and
federal contract opportunities before a
disaster strikes so they're ready to go
when needed and of course we heard from
senator baldwin about uh people dumping
um supplies that are not quality so ms
o'connell how did the gaps in our
domestic supply chain how did they
hinder kova knight the initial response
last year and what gaps remain today and
uh can you i want to work with you on
advancing a bipartisan solution to uh
strengthen our networks
senator rosen thank you so much for this
important uh for bringing up this
important topic and i would really look
forward to working with you as well uh
so when the pandemic first started we
experienced something where the whole
world wanted and needed the same
supplies at the exact same time and many
of them were being made
overseas
so in that time thanks to a lot of
funding that's come from
congress we've been able to invest
a billion dollars in various domestic
manufacturing efforts now that doesn't
fill all the gaps yet but we're
continuing to uh
to look at at various projects and and
send money out the door one of the
things we're doing that i think you'll
be interested in
is creating a domestic warm base
we're starting to see and we experience
that even at some phases in the pandemic
where demand for certain supplies
increased and then immediately decreased
and what we need is to have this warm
base so we for example are putting out
a statement of interest in
having 140 million n95s capacity to to
manufacture those per month
and having that warm base capacity we're
investing 115 million dollars in that
effort so we're trying to fill some gaps
and we're continuing to
look for opportunities great i look
forward to working on that with you and
dr fauci in that same vein
where we had critical
supply shortages as we think about ppe
and other things what about um critical
supplies of equipment and things for our
research labs how does that impact our
ability to do the research to advance
the latest treatments and how can we
overcome those challenges we had
reagents i know that we were trying to
get a lot of different things
yes that is an issue in some
circumstances senator where we have
certain reagents as you mentioned that
are not immediately available because of
supply chain issues and that's the
reason why
we get concerned when we have supply
chain interruptions which could impact
what we do at nih which is research
well thank you i hope look forward to
working on that and dr balenski
testing testing testing it's the key to
moving forward through a lot of this
whether you have vaccination treatments
or not we need robust testing and a lot
of people can't pay for the out of
pocket the turnaround can be slow so
what support is the federal government
providing to help states increase their
ability to have fast reliable and free
testing when it comes to labs and
staffing that is critical for our
economy people to go back to work
absolutely and we've been working very
closely with states and jurisdictions in
order to roll out testing free testing
and free testing support um we are
working closely with states we've uh and
schools we've rolled out 10 billion
dollars thanks to you and the american
rescue plan to provide testing in
schools and importantly personnel school
nurses
as well as the technical assistance as
to how and tool kits for our schools as
to how we use these tests where best to
use which test and then peer-to-peer
school advisors if a school wants to
roll out a testing program how you might
do that and how they might work with
another school to understand what the
challenges are and how to overcome them
yeah schools are key well i see that my
time has expired thank you all again
appreciate it and uh madam chair thank
you senator marshall thank you madam
chair i want to start by asking
unanimous consent to submit several
documents the first are 40 publications
that support
natural immunity 40 publications
the next i want to submit is a cdc
uh briefing that dr walinsky was kind
enough to bring to our attention it was
dated october 29 to this year science
brief cars sars cov2 infection induced
in vaccine immunity and want to call to
everyone's attention as the cdc points
out here the immunity provided by
vaccine
and prior infection are both high but
not complete the immunity provided by
vaccine and prior infection are both
high but not complete and for now the
last
what i'd like to submit is
something the cdc's mmwr
volume 7 october 29
2021 laboratory confirmed covid 19 among
adults hospitalized along with that a
review
by a dr martin kuldorf as well as some
comments some from some 20 positions i
asked just to look at the study just
with concerns about that particular
study
without objection
you know this morning i'd like to focus
on
immune versus non-immune
as opposed to conflating
those who have natural immunity plus the
vaccination
i will give you there are some studies
that would support
some benefit to giving a vaccine to
those who are already immune from
natural immunity i give you that but the
issue today i want to really lock in on
is natural immunity versus vaccination
immunity
we could have a frank debate i'm sure
all day long about the pros and cons and
i would think that if we were given the
lecture to our medical students we would
probably say the jury's still out
and
here's all the information and the data
and i think that's why we have
physicians to be able to look at this
data and look at this particular
person's medical history
about do we feel the benefits of this
vaccine outweigh the risk
and
dr wolinski i just my question for you
is going to be are you so convinced
that this data is
is so much in favor of that the vaccine
by itself is better than natural
immunity by itself are you so
inclined to give that that advice to the
white house
and separate the navy seal that i talked
to yesterday from the military a young
healthy navy seal
he's probably got oh my goodness if he
gets coveted a one out of a million
chance of having a serious
hospitalization at the same time he has
a 50 out of a million chance of getting
heart swelling which knocks him out of
being a navy seal at least for six
months and probably forever are you so
convinced that the data is so compelling
that natural immunity isn't as good as
vaccination again don't complain the two
together are you so convinced that the
the nurses i worked with uh in liberal
when there's through this epidemic was
roaring the the union worker at wolf
creek nuclear plant that kept the
electricity on months ago that we we
held as heroes that now we're going to
punish them and separate them from the
job we took an oath to do no harm
are you so convinced is the data so
compelling that you think that's what we
should do
thank you senator for that question
first let me just go back to the the
initial point which um i i don't want to
conflate them but let me just say i
think the studies are uniform that
vaccination after um after that's not my
question right i understand that so i
want to make sure that we correct the
record because i do believe that you
said something i said that three times i
think that those are uniform okay so if
we're looking at infection-induced
immunity versus vaccine-induced immunity
and we did transparently put a full
review of the literature that's out
there 96 studies i think if we were
talking to our medical students we would
tell them that we do not have a
correlate of protection we can't measure
whether you are protected or not and we
do know by virtue of the fact that our
vaccine-induced immunity studies know
for certain a date that we can follow
what those correlates of protection are
and effectiveness studies and we don't
have the capacity not only do we not
have a correlative protection i
apologize i i need to move on i
apologize next i want to submit for the
record um
ask unanimous consent uh first of all is
an email from peter dasik dated july 11
2016 it says dear ginny this is terrific
we're very happy to hear that our gain
of function research funding pause has
been lifted our gain of function
funding pause has been lifted
along with of course the studies that go
along with that dr fauci who reviewed
the grant
the grant proposal and this is of course
the one that's in the news
1r01a
i 110964
project title understanding the risk of
bat chronovirus emergence who reviewed
the grant proposal who made the decision
that the grant would not be subject to
the pause of gain and function who came
up with the language allowing exemptions
to be made was it the awardee or eco
health
senator i'm not so sure what you're
asking you say did i do that no i'm
asking who who would make that type of
decision
as to what
who would decide to make a pause in the
viral gain of function
decision for this particular research
policy uh this research request again
from eco health it stated 5 27 2014
that peter dasik would
respond this is terrific we're very
happy to hear that our gain of function
research funding pause has been lifted
yeah yeah who would make that decision
okay so i think conflating the words
gain of function research pause
the question is it was asked of the
trained staff at the institute
if this
research would fall under
the pause for gain of function and it
was determined by trained staff that it
did not because at that time there were
two components of guard rails there's
the guard rail of prior to 2017
which is whether or not an experiment is
designed
to enhance the transmissibility or the
power right now we understand that we've
been through the device so that didn't
rise to your level senator senator
marshall your your time has expired we
have two additional senators plus
closing i think these are very important
questions that america would like to
know the answer to
and and if you could submit them for the
record i wouldn't we could get a result
will you commit dr patchy to answering
our questions that we're going to submit
to the for the record
we always answer questions that are
submitted to the record of course thank
you thank you
senator lujan
thank you very much chair murray and
ranking member burr
and i very much appreciate my colleagues
comments and
attention to ensuring maximum
vaccination in the united states
especially ensuring all american
children who are eligible get vaccinated
because of that line of questioning i'm
able to turn my attention
in another area that has been
talked about a bit today but i hope we
can dig a little deeper
and although the united states is making
progress vaccinating people
i'm concerned about the low level of
vaccination in low and moderate income
countries
for interconnected border states like
new mexico
our physical and economic health depend
on international cooperation
much of the world remains unvaccinated
and that puts americans health and
prosperity at risk
though 49.6 of the world's population
has received at least one dose of cobalt
vaccine
only 3.7 percent of people in low-income
countries have and yet in the united
states 15 million vaccines have been
thrown away since march 1.
dr fauci i appreciate your comments to
senator smith on this topic and again
i'd like to dig in a little more
dr fauci do low vaccination rates
concentrated in parts of the world allow
covid to spread unchecked
yes senator and that's the reason why
as i've stated publicly very often that
a global pandemic requires a global
response
because when you have vaccine dynamics
that are rather robust in countries that
are under vaccinated
then what could conceivably happen may
be likely certainly there will be
mutations
and sometimes mutations
aggregate to the point that they lead to
a new variant which would be of concern
particularly if that variant has the
potential of evading the vaccines that
we already have
dr foucher you anticipated both of my
follow-up questions which were asking
about the concerns with new variants and
evading vaccinations that are currently
available now i open this question up to
the panel yes or no do low vaccination
rates in large swaths of the world put
the united states health and economic
recovery in jeopardy uh dr walensky
we absolutely need a global response i
think that the line is no one is safe
until everyone is safe dr fauci
definitely yes dr woodcock yes
mr carlo
yes
dr woodcock the more
attention that is brought to this area
my question is what more can be done
or can we be doing in the united states
to ensure countries
have the data they need to approve
vaccinations in country
during a recent visit with other
colleagues
we found out that some countries had not
yet approved
vaccines that were available across the
united states and many parts of the
world
well we post as much information as we
can we post our reviews which have a
large amount of information the material
that goes before the advisory committees
is all posted and also we participate in
an international collaboration called
igra that
for
often i'll be on a call there'll be
representatives from 90 to 100 different
countries it's only regulators and we
talk about the challenges and how we can
overcome them and specifically as a
vaccine area so
the fda is very happy to collaborate to
the extent we can by law with any
country to help them
with their regulators and getting
information that they need you said
something very key there that the fda is
happy to work with others
um as long as the law allows
and one of the areas that i'm very
interested in pursuing is what is not
allowing the united states to fully
work with other countries in this space
the united states has actively engaged
in international efforts like kovacs and
other regulatory harmonization efforts
but the reality is that low-income
countries remain largely unvaccinated
while the amount of discarded vaccines
is a small percent of vaccine doses
successfully administered
each wasted dose represents a missed
opportunity to protect the health of a
person and stop the spread
and so how can we maximize that and i'm
very interested in pursuing
what is standing in its way how can we
increase those efforts what's
uh required for us to work with
countries so that they have a rapid
response ready to go i learned that that
exists in ecuador even in areas of
indigenous communities where they've
proven that if they can get the vaccine
they can get into people's arms
relatively
efficiently
and so madam chair i want to be
respectful of my other colleagues i'll
submit the remainder of my questions
into the record i want to thank each of
the experts that are here today and i
look forward to working with each and
every one of you to get more people
vaccinated and stop the spread of kovac
thank you so much thank you senator
moran
chairwoman thank you u.n ranking member
and witnesses thank you for joining us
now this afternoon
first dr lewinsky
i'm interested in learning
what the administration's plan may be in
regard to
uh
vaccination mandate
uh just days ago you signed off on the
emergency use authorization for
pediatric uh covet 19 vaccine
the issue of mandates is roiling across
the country
and there while there are many parents
who are interested and willing to get
their their young children vaccinated
there are also other parents who still
question the pediatric use of emergency
authorization
and are concerned about a potential
federal vaccine mandate
i share the concern about federal
vaccine mandate i
urged the cdc and the administration
against implementing a vaccine mandate
for students
forcing parents to vaccinate their
children as a requirement to attend
public school would be without a doubt a
federal overreach
federal government mandates
for children to attend school that would
represent an extreme departure from our
educational systems historic
long-standing reliance upon local
and state control
and in my view the decision to vaccinate
a child should be left to the parent and
their trusted
physician it's a private relationship
the federal government should not be
inserting itself into with a mandate
perhaps all that commentary is
unnecessary and you can just assure me
that that is not
what is the next step in mandates from
the biden administration and if
if just you can only answer maybe
perhaps you can't answer what the bite
administration is going to do but what
is your thoughts and what would your
recommendation be
um thank you senator moran i am
delighted that this week we were able to
strongly recommend
that 28 million children receive a
cova-19 vaccine to prevent infection to
prevent severe disease long-covered
multi-fl multisystem inflammatory
syndrome as well as death in the
children that we have seen between the
ages of 5 and 11.
those recommendations are strong they
are after endorsement of the fda's
emergency use authorization
vaccine requirements are like for
schools are left to the local
jurisdiction and so we will leave those
to the local jurisdiction to make those
decisions so
kansas parents who may have concerns
about whether or not their children will
be able to attend school
that will not be a decision that's made
by with without a vaccine that's not a
decision that will be made by the cdc or
the biden administration but remain a
local
decision to be made by a local board of
education
i will always encourage that parent to
get their child vaccinated and
speak to them about the information and
communication and education that they
need in order to get their children
vaccinated
right now at this moment those decisions
are made at the jurisdictional level as
they are for vaccination of other all
other
vaccine-preventable diseases among
children i felt better when you said
before you said right now and that just
causes me to again ask is there any
intention to change that long-standing
practice not to my knowledge thank you
let me call on ms o'connell
uh ms o'connell i've been a supporter
and uh and and seen the value a long
time ago as a house member
uh i offered a moran ten point plan on
saving uh health care costs of reducing
health care costs one of those
components is the value of community uh
health centers and i'd like to give you
the opportunity to tell me what
it is that can be done should be done to
continue to include those community
health centers who have played an
integral part in combating covet 19
that they're
capable more capable and prepared
should there be another pandemic
well senator moran thank you this is one
of the things that you and i have in
common
a strong supporter of our federally
qualified community health centers our
rural health centers and the program
that hersa runs to support
both we've seen the fqhcs
play a significant role in distributing
vaccine
we're also running a pilot program right
now which
allows them to distribute free
at-home rapid tests to families and i
think that's another important way in
which they can contribute to this
response
we're hoping to scale that up by
thanksgiving right now it's in eight
states
we've also been able through the fqhcs
and rural health centers
distribute masks to families that might
need them high quality
masks and of course they continue to
provide
clinical care to families that
that seek their care there so
continue to see them play a significant
role
and we're always looking for
opportunities
to increase
the impact they can have in this
pandemic i thank you for that answer and
i want my community health centers to
know how valuable they are
not just in the time of a pandemic but
throughout
the daily life of lots of americans i
just visited one in kansas city kansas
last week
again reminded that they serve a very
valuable purpose
and a way for those who might not not
otherwise access the opportunity to have
a consultation with a health care
provider
to be able to do so and to make a
decision about how to care for
themselves and their families thank you
very much
thank you chairman thank you senator any
closing remarks
thank you madam chairman to all four of
our witnesses today thank you
for the job you do and more importantly
would you go back to the host of people
that are behind you in this work and
thank them on behalf of the committee
dr wolinski i didn't have this on my
list today but
the questions have precipitated it
um
do you really not know the answer to the
number of vaccinated individuals at cdc
or did you just not want to answer
senator cassidy's question
we're still actively working on
collecting those data and those data are
updated in real time
could you provide that for the committee
by monday of next week
i we are working towards updating those
data and i would have to speak with my
staff about where we are and whether
those numbers are going to be available
on monday dr wolinski i just remind you
that there's an executive order in place
for all federal agencies
that vaccinations for federal workers be
concluded by november 22nd
and it says that actual date is november
8th which is next monday because
disciplinary actions have to begin on
november the 9th
so if the collection is still in process
how are you going to start
uh disciplinary actions based upon the
executive order we're actively updating
those data i just don't know exactly
when they will be um fully in but um
certainly we will have those data by the
appropriate deadlines
well if cdc doesn't have to live by the
rules why should employers have to live
by the mandate rules
as i mentioned we will actively
make sure that we are complying with the
rules because we want everybody else to
as well as one last question because i
think what you've heard
is a frustration by members about
confusing messages that go out
it's confusion when somebody has to be
vaccinated though they've got natural
immunity it's confusing when
this policy is in place for mask and
then over here it's changed and i
realize this is an evolving thing
but correct me if i'm wrong
the cdc website currently says
that if you have had coveted in the last
90 days
and you leave the country
and you come back in you're not required
to be tested before you come to the
united states the website says we
recommend that within three to five days
of returning to the united states you
should have a cova test
i'll leave on sunday
i have double vaccination i have a
booster
next thursday in london i'll be required
to have a covet test in london before i
can fly back into the united states
the cdc's own website puts more value on
natural immunity than they do on
two vaccine shots and a booster shot
um
our guidance is intended first of all
let me just say i think our guidance is
very simple when it comes to vaccination
it has nothing to do with whether you've
been infected or not we recommend
everybody in this country be vaccinated
with either two doses of a fisa or
modern vaccine or a single dose of a
johnson johnson vaccine it couldn't be
more simple everyone should get
vaccinated who is eligible for to be
vaccinated
with regard to our with our ground to
our travel
our travel guidance and our travel
restrictions are to keep americans safe
to keep people traveling to the united
states safe
and to keep our local communities safe
let me repeat
what the guidance is
that if i leave the country and i've
been infected
and recovered from covet in the last 90
days i can come back in the country
without a requirement to be coveted
tested before i come in the country
though i'm recommended once i get in the
country to be to have a test within
three to five days
if
i'm vaccinated
and i'm boosted
if i leave the country i've got to
physically be tested outside the united
states before i can return to this
country i'm not asking a question i'm
making a point
that is so confusing that is so
confusing
that there's that there's every reason
to believe that the american people can
look at this and say what the hell are
you guys doing what are you judging this
based on it's not common sense and it's
certainly not science
the the scientific ground for these
tests is that these pcr tests can stay
positive up to 12 weeks and so what
we're working to prevent is that people
who would have a persistently positive
test from prior infection not be
confused with people who are newly
infected in that country they have to
they actually have to prove that they've
been had a positive test so we're not
looking um and and misdiagnosing them as
newly infected it's the science that's
informing that part your stated policy
suggests that you put more value on
natural immunity it does
it does it's the performance of the
diagnostic tests unfortunately
thank you madam chairman thank you
that will end our hearing today and i
want to thank our panelists um
uh and uh dr wolinski dr fauci dr
woodcock and assistant secretary
o'connell you've all been very patient
and we appreciate a very thoughtful
discussion
about our ongoing response to this
pandemic and the path forward and i
really do appreciate all of you being
here today for any senators who wish to
ask additional questions questions for
the record will be due in 10 business
days november 19th at 5 pm and with that
the committee stands adjourned
rock and roll
okay
thank
hey buddy
excellent ready thanks appreciate it
thank you so much
good luck and good luck to you
thank you
thanks
thanks
we'll come back
so i'm doing that
you